скільки можна рекламувати Якщо так можна
сказати Але дійсно я хочу про це
говорити тому що це велике поєднання і
крім фізичної культури Вчора я пам'ятаю
що ми говорили про те що дійсно там були
і математичні якісь вправи щось потрібно
було порахувати щоб зробити фізичну
вправу і ось ця комбінація цей синтез
фізкультури
інтелекту творчості ну настільки
переконливий вчора був для всіх нас і ми
були ми стали дійсно дійсно цими
свідками і ще за cool games School Grace
ви пам'ятаєте хто вже брав участь Хто
бачив Хто читав і я переконана в тому що
вчителі фізичної культури
культо-фізичної культури були присутніми
чи готували дітей Ну а про те що cool
games увійшли в шкільну програму і мають
бути на уроках фізичної культури не є
новиною ні для кого ну я наприклад про
себе скажу про свою дитину яка закінчила
п'ятий клас Закінчила вже йде в 6-й клас
можна говорити так то так він бачив у
мами футболку cool games і прийшовши до
школи е-е коли почув ось таку назву то
він сказав А да я вже був в курсі то що
ми про це говорить про те що наші
вчителі вчителі фізичної культури готові
навчатися готові розвиватися і
найголовніше що легко сприймають нове
тому що ну як не крути що можна жити за
старими стандартами і догмами Але ж це
не цікаво і не
мотивує дітей а ми вчителі - це ті хто
головний взірець на кого дивляться на
кого десь хотять бути схожими повторюю
повторювати Ну а вчитель фізичної
культури взагалі в стереотипах таким є
спортивним та активним здоровим дієвим
тому на вас рівняються і
за це за це вам велика подяка що ви не
зупиняєтеся з власне то сьогодні можна
було провести час по-різному погодьтеся
Да і поїхати на дачу і посидіти біля
телевізора і
зайнятися там шопінгом або інше але ви
тут ви слухаєте ви навчаєтеся ви берете
участь для того щоб
Дай Боже першого вересня почати навчання
в з нашими дітьми і навчати і мотивувати
їх тому друзі Дякую вам що ви небайдужі
і дякую вам за те що ви дійсно готові і
вчитися і хочете вчитися і у вас
дуже-дуже Круто получається ми будемо з
вами рухатися далі хочу нагадати що
окрім розрекламованих мною кіберфутболу
cool games і Cool Racing ще нас чекає
модель року з Марією глобою буде дуже
Я думаю що про свою колегу ви чули дехто
знайомий особисто сьогодні Олександр
Педан розповідав що з нею Він проводив
уроки фізичної культури що є дуже
цікавим я бачила спостерігаю за Марією в
Фейсбуці тому чесно кажу так був урок Я
бачила Я думаю що вже там далі про- про
цей урок ви скажете більше ніж я просто
глядач але все-таки дуже класно що ми
ось так синтезуємо всі разом нас чекає
ще сквош волейбол Dodge Ball ще не
говорить так і Падал теніс про це я
розкажу трошечки трошечки пізніше ну а
скоро скоро ми будемо з вами скоро ми з
вами будемо брати участь віртуально і
дивитися спостерігати навчатися
вуличному футболу тому так коли коли
коли Ігор скаже що там вже все готове ми
обов'язково до них доєднаємося а
вуличні вуличні футбол Ну що ж цікавий Я
думаю що футбол про футбол не знає Лише
ну дуже дуже лінива особистість
по-іншому ніяк не скажеш хтось активно
грає в футбол Хтось
такий як я мабуть
вболіває теж дуже активно і хто витрачає
більше емоції
чи тих гравців хто грає чи то хто
вболіває ще поки що невідомо хоча мені
здається коли мій папа дивиться футбол
то він готовий розгатити інколи плазму
Тому що тут дуже сильно вболіває ви мене
я зрозумієте тому що ми люди спортивні і
ви прекрасно прекрасно все розуміти тож
друзі бачите сьогодні дуже класний такий
Україну принаймні в Києві якщо когось
ненароком там дощіть або точки зі
столиці скоро до вас прийде сонце Да нам
жартувати і це говорю я яка сидить біля
віконечка з якого трошечки йде повітря а
Ігорю зараз на стадіоні будуть дуже
спекотно і чи вже дуже спекотно ну і
все-таки літо останні наші такі літні
дні коли можна
позасмагати тому що кого у кого освітян
з 1 вересня починається такі спекотні
дні вони спекотні не від сонця від того
що до школи повертаються діти які готові
сприймати готові навчатися і знову ж
таки готові дивитися що і як я
сподіваюся Ну звісно що Навряд чи ми
зможемо навчатися всі
офлайн на жаль на жаль такі є така є
ситуація в Україні але ж ми з вами що ми
з вами можемо вірити і віримо допомагати
і допомагаємо ЗСУ і головне що перемога
за нами і про це говорять абсолютно всі
і ми головне це віримо А Віра - Це вже
мабуть
98,99 відсотків за порука
Перемоги тому вірте друзі Все буде Все
Буде Україна все буде
активно
ох так що я хочу вам
що я хочу вам сказати про те що зараз
буде дуже класно така подія і активність
активність яка стала популярна ну можна
сказати що Давно А можна говорити що не
так давно не так давно Ну десь років
мабуть і сім-вісім Якщо я не помиляюся
коли так масово масово почали почали
входити в активність в у будь-якій сфери
нашого життя флешмоби ви ж прекрасно це
знаєте тому що і ви брали участь разом з
вчителями і учнями у флешмобах які були
ініційовані комітетом фізичного
виховання та спорту Міністерство освіти
і науки України тому це слово флешмоб не
звучить ніяк новим Ну а що ж сьогодні
запропонуємо запропоную вам Давайте
будемо дивитися хочу сказати що флешмоб
на підтримку захисників України і
ведучі флешмоби це вчителі
навчально-виховного комплексу Домінанта
Ну а беруть участь всі учасники нашого
серпневого семінару і діти які теж
присутні Сьогодні у нас наш учні наші і
відповідно вчителі тренери і всі-всі-всі
бажаючі так само можуть долучитися до
флешмобу на підтримку захисників України
побачимо подивимося що буде далі Поки що
є там декілька у нас хвилиночок
перепочити перевести дух попити водичку
Що наприклад я і зро тому що дійсно
водний баланс потрібно постійно
підтримувати це вже як порадити Тим паче
в таку спеку яка зараз у нас стоїть
на подвір'ї
вже спостерігати за готовністю
дітей йдуть останні останні приготування
останні
приготування і ви бачите я була права що
беруть участь бачити всіх маркеровані
футболки
і
всі-всі і дівчата і хлопці і Вадим
Стеценко ми можемо бачити посередині як
завжди я б не знаю знаєте буває так що
головуючий дає вказівки і сам
спостерігає Ну я ніколи не бачила Вадима
стасенка що він просто брав і
спостерігав завжди активно Ігор Ну і
мені теж потрібно футболка обов'язково
домовилася хоть Тут хоч я не брала
участь у віарі але футболку мені
обов'язково Ну що ж ми чекаємо початку
флешмобу на підтримку наших захисників
які ми вдячні тим що ми сьогодні разом з
вами зібралися тут і можемо зробити ось
такий
подих
буде Я сказала вже Катя звичайно ж і
футбол Великий вуличний і навіть
трішечки віртуальний ну а зараз ми
змогли зазирнути за лаштунки підготовки
нашого надзвичайного флешмобу це
розкішний репетиція Ой да тут же ж
суцільні VIP персони пане Вадима дуже
радий бачити Вадим Стеценко голова
комітету фізичного виховання та спорту
Міністерства освіти і науки України Ну
що ж як гаряче спекотно а драйв який
козацький це дуже круто тому що ми разом
діти вчителі всі разом танцюємо І робимо
флешмоб і я думаю що сам флешмоб буде
просто незабутнім повторюйте і ви і
будемо повторювати і Ми дякуємо
тільки вперед Ну що ж друзі ми бачимо
наскільки все згуртовано що долучилися
до нас багато учнівської молоді вчителі
та й бачимо вопіперсони також як інакше
тільки так згуртовано і разом ми
наближуємо нашу перемогу тому всі
секрети ми не будемо звичайно сьогодні
відкривати але дуже скоро Коли настане
цей момент ми і покажемо вам сам флешмоб
Ну що бачимо що йде підготовка вже я
замовкаю тому що цікаво подивитися
чогось наша славна Україна
зажурилася
А ми чують червону
[музика]
калину гудуть Червона калина
осінь
[музика]
завелася
ґрунтуйте мене
[музика]
нами нашу землю Україну
свою
зустріч Червона калина
[музика]
життя зажурилася
а мною червону калину підіймемо
малу Україну
[музика]
Ой у лузі червона калина похилилася
сашурилася
А ми чують червону
[музика]
картку
це флешмоб на підтримку захисників
України Так я думаю що кожен з вас Кожен
з нас не втомлюється просто дякувати
щодня щоранку проте коли ми відкриваємо
очі по будильнику або просто нас буде
сину донька онука і говорити Дякую за
суд Дякуємо тирео за те що ви бороните
наші життя наш спокій і за те що ми
можемо сьогодні зробити
вільний подих випити каву поспілкуватися
з друзями з близькими ще раз сказати що
любимо їх тому що Інколи буває такі в
голові дещо чи зможуть чи скажу Я завтра
про це своїм дітям або своїм батькам
тому друзі не треба відкладати на завтра
так ми дійсно Дякуємо ЗСУ на те що вони
нас боронять і
ще раз на їхню честь На честь найкращих
козаків у світі на честь нас на честь
українців тому що я не буду говорити про
статистику та про висновки експертів я
буду говорити про те що дійсно нація
українців стала найсильнішою
найзгуртованішою
найсміливішою і ось ці
най-най хочеться говорити постійно скоро
піднімемо ми нашу червону калину і
Україна розквітне ще з більшою силою
Віра Ми друзі
[музика]
слава
Україна
[музика]
- це не вона коли
в нас
[музика]
час зажурилася
ой
[музика]
у лузі на журілася
флешмоб на підтримку захисників наших
захисників і ще раз хочу сказати Велике
дякую вам хлопці і дівчата що боронити
нас І що ми можемо
що ми можемо дихати інколи вільно хоча
дійсно читаємо постійно новини слідкуємо
дивимося болить і вболіваємо але ми
знаємо що окрім як перемогою це не
закінчиться перемогою нашої тому що ми
найкращі ми українці і у нас найсильніша
армія в світі як би це зараз на звучало
але тісно це так гуртуємось для
загального фото тому що щось мені
підказує після того як вже ми нарешті
зможемо виконати наш флешмоб то буде
трішечки не до фото тому що буде надто
гаряче
і після цього В нас дуже особливий захід
буде показове в мене шоу Але це так
знаєте при відкритий інтригу ніяких
таємниць Ми ще не відкриваємо і з
приводу нашого фото як завжди на три і
Україна раз два три Україна
і ще раз один два три Руки догори раз
два три Україна
так ну що ж ми дізнаємося що зараз всі
вже дуже і дуже готові але є ще кілька
моментів приготування Ну по-перше я б
хотів сюди
запросити Світлану увімцеву господиню
цієї чудової наших місцини ще можна
більше Оплески навчально-виховного
комплексу Домінанта пані Світлану Як
настрій взагалі
вітаємо звичайно не можу не залучити
також і
Вадима Стеценка голову комітету
фізичного виховання та спорту
всіх вітають ми всі круті молодці ура
супер
Ну що ж мені подобається що ви не
розтанули друзі що ви готові а це
означає що в нас все готово до речі
Знайомтесь Ну тут всі знають Миколу
ганяти так так Всіх вітаю І хочу сказати
що сьогодні саме до нас ще долучилися
гості давайте їх теж привітаємо це
начальник Дніпровського районного
управління головного управління днс
України у місті Києві полковник служби
цивільного захисту шелхоз Ігор
Володимирович привітаємо заступник
начальника Дніпровського районного
управління головного управління ДСНС
України в місті Києві полковник кивнюк
Олег Васильович теж вас вітаємо вас дуже
раді бачити і вчора ми вже познайомились
це заступник начальника управління
начальник відділу Дніпровського е-е
днс України в місті Києві полковник
служби цивільного захисту Ткаченко Вадим
Анатолійович Ну що Ігор володимировичу
ми вас вітаємо Я впевнений вам є що
сьогодні сказати всім присутнім нашої
конференції будь ласка
Дякую велике спасибі за запрошення я
вітаю всіх хто приїхав славетну столицю
в нас славетний Дніпровський район який
носить імені нашого Прекрасну Славутича
розташований на березі Дніпра і семи
мостів міста Києва чи шість виходить на
території Дніпровського району і
сьогодні Зустріч отаке суцвіття дівчат
красивих мужніх хлопців Це свідчення
того що перемога наша буде буде
обов'язково як найближчим часом Ну а
всім учасникам ми вітають творчих
успіхів творчих злетів перемогу
олімпіадах І взагалі наш главний головне
наше направлення зараз це фізична
культурна культура і спортивне виховання
Я вас всіх Вітаю займаємося спортом і
всі приєднуються один до одного в цих
заняттях
Дякуємо вам Ну і як вчора казали що ми з
вами зустрінемось Саме тут да на
подвір'ї нашого навчально-виховного
комплексу Домінанта для того щоби разом
провести практично тренувальний захід
тож звичайно Прошу всіх учасників пройти
праворуч так да щоб ми все бачили
спостерігали за тим що зараз буде
відбуватися шановні друзі прошу вас Будь
ласка проходьте праворуч і з вами ми
будемо зараз е-е учасниками цього
дійства а саме практично тренувальний
захід з евакуації працівників та
здобучів освіти у разі загрози або
виникнення надзвичайних ситуацій на
території закладу освіти і Саме тут у
навчально-виховному комплексі Домінанта
буде відбуватись цей захід Дякуємо
Миколі і Микола на правах господаря
цього закладу ведучий
НВК Домінанта тому він вишикував знає
дещо і Звідки краще вибігати і де
зрештою знаходиться в нас також сховище
А це в нас Сирена тривога так дійсно
друзі саме зараз ми всі чуємо з вами
сигнал тривоги - Це довгий дзвоник який
сповістив нам всім про те що в нашому
закладі виникла пожежа через займання
електропроводки у комп'ютерних класах та
спровокувала евакуацію всіх працівників
та учнів закладу у приміщенні з
використанням первинних засобів
індивідуального захисту а саме
ватно-марлевих пов'язок у закладі
відбулася організована евакуація
учасників навчально-виховного процесу з
приміщення школи за схемами евакуації
під час евакуації
велика увага приділяла правилам
евакуації Це дійсно треба пам'ятати діти
покидали школу без паніки організовано
всі шляхи евакуації були вільними та
відкритими тому евакуація відбулася
через найближчі виходи при цьому
залишаючи приміщення кожен вчитель увага
кожен вчитель мав у кабінетах зачинити
всі вікна відкрити двері видати учням
ватно-марлеві пов'язки та винести із
приміщення класні журнали як основний
документ обліку учнів при надзвичайній
ситуаціїх таких як виникнення
вибуховано небезпечних предметів
надзвичайна ситуація на воді та пожежа
негайно слід викликати відповідні служби
допомоги служби надзвичайно ситуації і
пожежників за телефоном Я впевнений
знають 101 або 102 тож і ми сьогодні
опинився ж під час пожежі одразу
зателефонували е-е 101 і викликали
рятувальники на на допомогу при
перевірці учнів вчителів виявили
відсутність одного учня тож керівництво
закладу повідомило рятувальникам що в
кабінеті на третьому поверсі увага в
кабінеті на третьому поверсі
перебуває учень сьогодні роль учня буде
виконувати Наш вчитель е-е фізичного
виховання від якого ее деякий час немає
зв'язку і ми не знаємо що з ним
відбувається то що ми вже бачимо з вами
пожежний автомобіль
увага вони поспішають на наш виклик
керівництво нашого закладу повідомляє
про те що на третьому поверсі є учень
від якого немає зв'язку і ми не знаємо з
вами Що з ним трапилось тож я впевнений
нашим
рятувальників зможуть нам сьогодні
допомогти
[музика]
це рятувальники державної служби
надзвичайних ситуацій це наші рятівники
пожежники 13-ї пожежно-рятувальної
частини Дніпровського району та
аварійно-рятувальна служба які вже
поспішають на наш виклик Вони вже тут
вони вже готові зробити все для того щоб
врятувати нашого учня
увага шановні присутні
відбувається
[музика]
те що ми можемо з вами бачити сьогодні
дякувати Богу це умовна ситуація але ми
всі з вами повинні знати як треба себе
поводити що треба робити
вперше якщо в нас виникла така ситуація
в нашому закладі так друзі тільки будьте
обачними і не стійте на шляху наших
рятівників Я розумію що всі хочуть зняти
зробити селфі У вас ще буде така нагода
Отож ми зараз дійсно стаємо свідками
таких навчань цього городу але вони дуже
і дуже наближені до реальності адже ж
Всі розуміють що ми дуже часто понад усе
говоримо про збройні сили України але
Повірте в такій непростий час дуже і
дуже великий внесок в нашу перемогу
роблять наші працівники
ДСНС України ви розумієте скільки було і
на півдні на півночі і на сході в центрі
країни і навіть на заході в них роботи і
вони ризикуючи своїм життям А ми
розуміємо що подекуди навіть і віддаючи
своє життя так само як медики лікарі
вони роблять все це для безпеки України
і ми зараз є теж свідками цього служіння
цієї роботи
шановні присутні наші учасники гості так
трошечки можна
спостерігати проходи трошки ліворуч Що
зараз ви бачили як ми рятуємо
нашого учня саме з третього поверху
навчально-виховного комплексу Домінанта
Я хочу ще раз е-е сказати всім вам буде
обережні бо працюють справжні
професіонали своєї справи а саме це е
13-те пожежно-рятувальна частина
Дніпровського району та
аварійно-рятувальна служба
які вже з нами і вони вже готові
допомогти для того щоб врятувати нашого
учня ми спостерігаємо друзі і саме зараз
ми будемо бачити як це буде відбуватись
хочу
є декілька запитань до
Ігора Володимировича він сьогодні з нами
Ігоре володимировичу будь ласка Ми вас
бачимо
ми всі
Хвилюємось Але я впевнений що ваша
бригада зможе з цим впоратись Скажіть
будь ласка що саме відбувається по-перше
коли ваші рятівники приїжджають на ось
такий виклик
навчань нам було повідомлено ще один очі
не співу рахуватися зі школи
внаслідок завалу на коридорі є єдиний
шлях як його евакуювати це зняти його по
автодрабіні ви бачите прибув автомобіль
пожежно-рятувальний драбина висотою 30
метрів яка встановила автотригери ніколи
драбину не розставляється з колес
видвигається бачите автотригери і зараз
вони будуть подавати люльку до вікна для
того щоб евакувати учні який подає
ознаки життя з третього поверху
службового класу
після того як ми евакує учні дальше
будемо показувати медичну частину і так
далі І так далі ви бачите що подається
люлька спеціально для того щоб
евакуювати учня який просить про
допомогу
взагалі ця драбина до себе до поверху
житлових будинків
Ну що ж інтригуючий момент і безумовно
друзі ми розуміємо що це навчання але
воно дуже наближене до реальності і
наші працівники ДСНС України завжди
готові стати на захисті народу України
тому зараз ми бачимо як
підіймається спеціальний кран і як буде
відбуватися евакуація
ми вже бачимо нашого учня на третьому
поверсі і впевнені саме зараз
відбудеться е-е
евакуація цього нашого учня який е так
вийшло опинився е-е і не зміг разом з
нашими зі всіма учнями вийти врятуватися
але Ми впевнені що наші рятівники
зможуть це зробити і зроблять це в свій
час і все буде гаразд Ну що ми бачимо як
працює техніка
[музика]
спостерігаємо в режимі наживо абсолютно
так як воно може бути в реальному житті
жодних знаєте репетицій і жодних там
моментів паузи там зйомок з кращих
ракурсів Ось так само як ви зараз
прямісінько дивитесь так воно буває і в
реальному житті хотелося б щоб таких
привидів так для цих моментів було менше
Але ми точно знаємо що наші героїчні
рятівники завжди ладні І готові стати на
захист українців і дійсно ми розумі
беремо те що вони ризикують своїм життям
задля того щоби звичайно врятувати інше
питання Ігор Володимирович Скажіть будь
ласка
які які відчуття
повинна бути своєчасний час для того щоб
людина не залишать одного разу і в нас
його не його не отримали отруєння тому
Тому перш за все потрібно
виконати завдання друге питання ви
розумієте що десь 10 років нас не
питання швидше швидкість
на допомогу потерпілому медичні
працівники вже готові до виконання своїх
завдань і
все це буде проходить Ви повинні
побачити як воно повинно бути так
максимально приближеним до практики
і ось майже ми вже бачимо як ось-ось ми
врятуємо учня який залишився на третьому
поверсі нашого закладу тож можна
приготувати долоні друзі тому що дійсно
Сьогодні ми з вами бачимо як це повинно
відбуватися і звичайно треба запам'ятати
що робити якщо виникає така ситуація Ну
і що
ось вже ми поблизу і звичайно
чекаємо
нашого учня для того щоб надалі
продовжувати
ризикуючи своїм життям вони звичайно
рятують інше життя тож можна поплескати
в долоні друзі звичайно підтримка - це
круто І сьогодні ми Дякуємо нашим
рятівникам які сьогодні
прибули на наш виклик для того щоб
врятувати учня Ну що ми чекаємо вас І
далі звичайно хочемо передати нашим
медикам які вже готові надати першу
домедичну допомогу нашому учню
[музика]
ще одна людина яка залишилась у закладі
цього Ого учня ми вже змогли врятувати
давайте поплескаємо нашим рятівникам але
є ще один постраждалий який зараз е-е
наші рятівники вже виносять з нашого
закладу будь ласка увага і звичайно
треба надати е-е цьому постраждалому
першу домедичну допомогу тому шановні
друзі ми з вами праворуч переміщаємось
сюди до наших рятувальників медичних
рятувальників які будуть надавати першу
домедичну допомогу шановні друзі
підходьте трошечки ближче але так щоб ми
змогли всі бачити і треба запам'ятати що
ми будемо робити трошечки ширше ширше
стоїмо друзі так так так так так так і
ми вже готові почути і звичайно побачити
що треба робити тож увага шановні друзі
Хочу надати слово - це фельдшер
рятувальник аварійно-рятувального загону
ДСНС міста Києва
Надія вітаємо вас тож розкажіть нам будь
ласка що ми робимо одразу як до нас до
вашої руки е-е попадає так да
постраждали будь ласка
[музика]
самі
оточуючим потерпілим Ну то есть
потерпілим оточують людям оточуючим вам
перше що ми маємо зробити це е-е
дивіться про дивимося людина у нас
бриттями чи ні Якщо людина щоб знати то
есть вона
сознание чи безсоння ми трясимо плечу І
кажемо з вами все гаразд дивіться Він
відкрив очі бачите хтось перший варіант
хтось людина притягує відкрила очі на на
нас дивиться реагує ми запитуємо все
гаразд Так вона каже все гаразд
Залишаємо її лежати до приїзду швидкої
допомоги і слідкуємо за її станом так
наступний приклад ми трясимо і за плече
і питаємо з вами все гаразд вона не
реагує тобто не подає ознак життя що ми
повинні перевірити перший на перше ми
повинні виконати прийом чути бачити
відчувати що це означає ми
Дивіться
нагинаємось до людини до вуха
прикладаємо вухо до над її ртом
двома пальцями руки тому Люба рука
кладемо на сонні артерій
і цим вже хтось поки ми так нагнулися ми
дивимось очима на грудну клітину чути
бачити відчувати тобто чути бачити
відчувати це визначається наявність
пульсу та дихання Тобто ми слухаємо 10
секунд для цього нам потрібно для
визначення наявності серцебиття та
дихання 10 секунд Тобто ми робимо так
раз
пульс є людина в нас без свідомості але
пульс є що ми в цьому випадку робимо
далі Тобто вона дихає серце б'ється але
просто на заході без свідомості якщо у
вас Ну у нас От дивіться потерпіло вже
пристебнутий ми зазвичай в карету
швидкої його поміщаємо і відвозимо до
лікувального злакладу але якщо на етапі
до медичної допомоги у вас ще не
викликали швидку Вона ще не приїхали у
вас людина
дихає серце б'ється але вона
не притямі то ми його її переводимо
стабільне положення як це робиться
так
це дуже просто це може виконати навіть
якщо людина важить там 150 даже там під
200 Кіло це може виконати дівчина якоїсь
десь ну вага 40 кг тобто легко його
перевернути тут важлива техніка Що ми
робимо
тобто
Ми йдемо руку до себе одну раз далі далі
Поліна підгибаємо
отак два ричаг це використовуємо як
ричаг
тому ось однією рукою сюди другою сюди
дочки відходимо
і верхні це треба робити
далі у цьому положенні дивіться буває
при випадках при отруєнні чадним газом
людина може виникнути спонтанне блювання
якщо ми залишаємо на спині то вона може
при
захлинутися при спонтанному блюванні
просто-напросто захлинутися стабільне
положення - це таке положення в якому
воно безпечне то есть вона щоб вона нас
не захлинулася не було за падіння язика
Дихала серцебиття билось ну серце билось
нормально перевели стабільне Положення
наблюдаємо за ним періодично перевіряємо
пульс все і чекаємо на швидку допомогу
в стабільному положенні
тобто перша домедична допомога ми змогли
надати нашому пострадалу бачимо що все
гаразд так і є ще третій варіант Якщо у
нас лежить потерпілий тобто перевіряємо
наприклад час іще остання Тобто ми
перевірили чути бачити відчувати Але у
нас відсутні пульс і дихання Що ми
робимо в цьому випадку в цьому випадку у
нас головний орган у людини це мозок нам
треба його зберегти для цього нам надо
відновити дихання та серцебиття Що ми
робимо перше
перевіряємо прохідність дихальних шляхів
кладемо руку на лоба обережно одну під
шию
розпрямляємо дихальні шляхи далі
пальчика кладемо на підборіддя
відкриваємо рота І заглядаємо Бо у нас
людина може Ми продовжуємо пані Надія де
рятувати нашого постраждалого зверніть
увагу будь ласка шановні друзі так ще
виникнення пожежі Дана на території
нашого закладу
і треба треба зробити так щоб його
загасити і Звичайно є учасник нашої
конференції який вже готовий спробувати
це зробити разом з нашими рятівниками Ну
що друзі
подивимось да за допомогою чого
трошечки пізніше ми будемо продовжувати
далі рятувати але з ним все гаразд Ми
впевнені в цьому і ми бачимо що саме
учасник нашої конференції зараз одягає
цей спецодяг для того щоби спробувати
теж загасити цей вогонь друзі будьте
обережні тож полум'я розповсюджується і
може
може бути наслідки тож трошечки далі
відходимо і ігри володимировичу Скажіть
будь ласка за допомогою чого ми будемо
це робити
ви бачите полум'я і ми його Василь будем
первинним засобів пожежогасіння
вогнегасник ви бачите дуже легко
практично в одну хвилину в одну секунду
пожежа була погашена при тому що Це ваша
Ваш друг ваш співробітник який не
спеціально відібраний для цього
настільки легко що ми можемо навіть
якусь жінку бажають чи запросити
показати як це робиться
Може хтось ідіть боюсь
А може ще хтось хоче спробувати є
бажаюче ось добре Будь ласка підходьте
підходьте будь ласка Да до Ігора
Володимировича Ігор володимировичу Ось у
нас є ще бажаючою Ось так теж учасник
нашої конференції Ось такі вони наші
вчителі і бачите так мужні спортивні і
звичайно вони готові це зробити це
спробувати
А ми дивимось і звичайно теж шановні
присутні дивіться та
як це робиться так нічого страшного Ось
так нічого не треба боятися все
скільки скажіть скільки три так три
секунди і вогню вже немає будь ласка так
да
здатний виконувати дуже багато функцій і
зараз ми покажемо як він працює як він
носить пожежі спеціально розпильонна
струя есть поливає ви бачите
дуже спекотно сьогодні так Так ви бачите
що можна робити це дуже крута така
машина да яку подарувала
нещодавно відбулася подія так да була
подарована ця
машина яка Ось так обережно обережно
друзі
так так
Ну що давайте ще раз поаплодуємо Друзі
нашим рятівникам Щиро дякуємо
представникам районного управління
Державної служби з надзвичайних ситуацій
України Дніпровського району в місті
Києві
виступ і створення реального рятувальної
обстановки під час надзвичайної ситуації
Ну що шановні друзі прошу зробити
спільне фото сьогодні відбулася Ось така
подія дякувати Богу це е
всі до машин підходимо робимо спільне
фото І кажемо дійсно дякувати Богу що
сьогодні була умовна ця рятувальна
рятувальна наша тренування Дякуємо всім
і дійсно Я хочу нагадати що наш Захід не
завершується як тільки шановні присутні
ви почуєте сигнал тривоги ми всіх
учасників
Запрошуємо до укриття який знаходиться в
нашому закладі тобто Як тільки ви
почуєте сигнал тривоги Ми вас чекаємо і
разом будемо
крокувати до укриття
Ну що ж Дякуємо Миколі Дякуємо нашій
суперкоманді ДСНС України дійсно приємно
розуміти і знати що про нас піклуються і
в нас багато в країні героїв із збройні
сили України звичайно наші лікарі наші
вчителі і освітяни і ДСНС України завжди
на висоті я хочу сказати зараз для всіх
вчителів увага що за планом у вас буде
дуже-дуже скоро у спортивному залі
модель уроку фізкультури разом з Марією
глобою тому не проґавте не Пропустіть і
звичайно в нас є сьогодні дуже велика
насичена програма бачите тут мене ледь
не підмочили А чому б ви Ні дуже
спекотно на дворі Хоча я пожартував якщо
цього пане
пожежний Отож наші сьогодні і vr-футбол
буде віртуальний футбол подивимось Хто
кращий І там обов'язково і cool games
куди ж ми без cool games і звичайно що
багато вуличних в нас буде активностей
будьте з нами Слідкуйте Ну а вчителям
фізичної культури я Нагадую що модель
уроку від Марії глоби ідіть поспішайте
туди спортивний зал Ну а я піду в душ
і увага шановні Наші учні увага е перша
команда перша команда - це колгеймс ми
прямуємо на е-е футбольний майданчик
через 5 хвилин
готуємось перша команда так Да ми з вами
будемо поспішати на футбольний майданчик
ви всі знаєте де це знаходиться а-а
друга команда
курейс Ми вас чекаємо праворуч від
футбольного майданчику ми бачимо там вас
вже чекають яскраві такі пристрої на
яких ви зможете змагатись і показати на
що ви здібні і що далі
і третя команда кіберфутбол - це у нас
актова зала почули всі Да третя команда
Кіпр футбол - це у нас актова зала через
5 хвилин ми вас чекаємо тож будьте
уважними
[музика]
Ну що друзі Ми чуємо сигнал повітряної
тривоги тому вчителі
та наші гості будь ласка пройдіть в
укриття
[музика]
можемо крокувати саме зо мною
шановні вчителі наші гості ми вас
Запрошуємо
лунає сигнал повітряної тривоги і пройти
в укриття
[музика]
я вас чекаю
і будемо разом разом разом разом
збираємося разом
разом разом
Ідемо до укриття бо
[музика]
[оплески]
краще складається стрільба і завдяки ній
посів та місцях
[музика]
талановита треба з ними Працювати треба
проводити більше для них закладів
зацікавлювати їх працювати з ними І це
буде в майбутньому добре
[музика]
[оплески]
виступала я в гімназіаді у спирту і
індивідуальній гонці здобула в спирту
третє місце і індивідуального НКВ перше
місце
ми за рік за два за три можливо за 4
отримаємо покоління спортсменів які
пройшовши дистанції гімназіант будуть
показувати непогані і високі результати
на професійних дорослих змаганнях
[музика]
шановні учасники європейських
університетських ігор гордий тим що ви
будете представляти нашу державу та
університети України в наймасштабніших
європейських студентських змаганнях які
відбудуться у Польщі у місті Лодзь
[музика]
[оплески]
Вітаю Україну з успіхом на європейських
університетських іграх ми другі за
кількістю медалей це внесок кожного з
нас у перемогу України Ще завдяки
студентам та їх той не дам ректором
федерація з видів спорту а особливо
вдячність Міністерство освіти і науки
України та європейська асоціація
університетського господарства Слава
Україні
[музика]
[оплески]
Це гол і Це гол і Це гол команда
всерівно показує що їм не так вже і все
рівно на результат і забиває гол і
забиває гол друзі Ми вже тут на локації
кіберфутболу Ну хто ж хлопчаків і не
лише хлопчиків але й дівчаток не грав у
Fifa можливо на комп'ютері чи на
Playstation як у нас все дуже потужно і
сучасна та все навіть не те щоб круто по
кіберспортивному але й по футбольному в
нас тут навіть коментатор є а як же
звичайно Микола Вітаю Як настрій настрій
дуже чудовий тому що насправді відчуває
безліч емоцій і головне що мене радує в
цьому матчі який ми зараз з вами можемо
спостерігати що обов'язково переможе
Україна О оце ідеальна комбінація
подивіться в нас навіть стільці
відповідного кольору під колір форми
збірної України виїзний синій і домашній
жовтенький А давайте трохи ще
повідволікаємо наших футболістів так за
жовту збірну України Це в нас
Станіслав
Станіслав дуже напружений тому що щойно
ледь у ворота Станіслава не залетів м'яч
від
Івана Отож Іван проти Станіслава
Станіслав Давай будемо відволікати тебе
за яку команду вболіваєш
Зоря Шахтар та Реал Мадрид нормальний
такий список Отож в Європі це Реал
Мадрид в Україні Луганська Зоря та
донецький Шахтар А як буде у Івана
Ну що значить все А в Україні Динамо
Київ
Вчора дивився динамо- Бенфіка плакав
я ледь не плакав тому що хотілося щоб
виграла але не склалося Ну що ж в нас
тут як бачимо Іван із Станіслав А є що
сказати Так у нас тут є коментар як
звати тебе
Як тебе звати
Вова ти любиш футбол
Хто твій Фаворит футболістів давай
почнемо
молодець пам'ятаєш наших легенд це
приємно
[музика]
футбол
2:0 програли але ми вам відігратися
другого батька тобто Ти впевнений що на
стадіоні далуш в Лісабоні в Португалії і
динамівці вийдуть і дадуть так на горіхи
прочуханки тим португальця
слухайте
Ану можна мене в кадр
пане Мірча Луческу посуньтеся тут у нас
є тренер впевненістю який виведе
динамівців до групового етапу Ліги
чемпіонів молодець і звичайно бажаємо
успіху ти ще не грав сьогодні
наступний на черзі
а третій
яку команду обереш
за збірну України Молодці Як бачимо
молоде покоління в нас і пам'ятає про
наших легенд про знане минуле але вони
вже тут і зараз готові будувати велике
майбутнє великої спортивної І взагалі
великої України Ну а ми скоро побачимо
що ж там в нас в нашій cool games і Cool
Racing Ну а поки що по вболіваємо за
хлопців Я впевнена Ігор чомусь Що на
цьому етапі ми тебе точно загубимо тому
що всі знаємо який ти активний
вболівальники гравець футболу сів Як то
кажуть на коня і
впевнена що хто Хто А ти спробуєш себе
тут точно тому що футбол - це те що те
що ти любиш те з чим ти захоплюєшся те
що тим живеш Ну що йдемо далі дати
проносував що далі у нас cool games
School Grace ми будемо далі дивитися
можемо ще по спостерігати трошечки за кі
футболом да як хлопці грають звісно
приємно дивитися на наші рідні кольори
Це вже я їх говорю просто як жінка дане
трохи хоча сказали про Шевченка хочу
сказати думаю що ви точно знаєте що він
зараз дуже активний такий волонтери
займає позиція активні на про
розголошення війни в Україні по всьому
всесвіту тому велика подяка п Андрію
Шевченку що він далі продовжує відсвоїв
відстоювати
не лише українські спорт і футбол Ну а
звісно те що зараз на часі актуальна
давайте подивимося ще трошечки на футбол
мене навчився бить пенальті в цій грі
треба вимкнути приціл підказують
досвідчені гравці нажати здається правий
ага
і це не
перетиск кнопочка
а він довго не натискав і
Україна Україна
і матч завершено перемогою синьої
команди команди все рівно і давайте ми
будемо
нецільно радіти і не сильно
засмучуватися тому що це поки що
один мінус перемога один все-таки будемо
рахувати так як збиралися рахувати
А в нас відбулася заміна Давайте ми
зіграємо 4 гри як планувала а тоді
подивимося дуже красива гра чоловіки які
зараз мене слухають ви скажуть А чого ти
про що ти взагалі але
знаєте не будучи гравцем ми не буде чи
великим фанатом футболу Я просто
задивилася і деякий час сиділа мовчки
тому що дійсно дуже класно а й
найголовніше те що можна пограти
пограти наче наче відчути себе гравцем
таких улюблених для себе команди
України Я думаю не думає впевнена що не
лише аж не правильно не лише ж Україна
Да бо в FIFA всі команди є раджу раджу з
колегами ще порядку друзі цікава цікава
гра як для варіант знаю що дуже багато
часу проводять і діти Хоча і багато
дорослих якщо чесно Фіфа грається вона
затягує і нещодавно свого чоловіка
вмовила не купувати приставочку щоб він
не грав в FIFA Ось так я вчинила але за
це мабуть якщо він ще раз це почує це
точно купить Ну що ж а ми вже бачимо
наступний екран з праворуч від нас
тренується вже тренуються і не лише
тренуються а навчаються наші колеги
вчителі на чолі з Марією Глоба я
пам'ятаєте що я анонсувала цей
майстер-клас
урок модель уроку і модель уроку
фізичної культури №2 Марія Глобал в нас
з Черкас з мого рідного міста і мені ще
ще
приємніше так і оголошувати
бачимо що беруть участь наші колеги
вчителі
хустиночками ну зараз послухаємо
побачимо
не створять хоча можливо вам зараз
цікавинки такі
воротар знову потягнув Зінченко схопився
за голову
так само і відчув мабуть
гра називатися хитра лисичка ми чіпляємо
хустинки собі хвостики такі
при можливості так щоб вони були у нас
назовні щоб ми їх дуже дуже гарно бачили
дуже добре а тепер підніміть руку хто
вважає себе найшвидшим серед усіх
є Женя а тут є хтось в нас такий на цій
половині
є хлопчика Анатолій давай ти зі мною
поділишся своїм хвостиком
треба поділитися треба поділитися Ми
сьогодні будемо соціалізуватися в нашій
компанії Женічка поділіться зі мною будь
ласка Отже це в нас опинилися такі хитрі
лисички які будуть намагатися досягнути
успіху Да і отримати цю хустинку самі
собі свій гості тобто у нас розділена
зала на дві частини і Звичайно ця
компанія працює в цій половинці
обмеженими лініями хочу вас застерегти
за технікою безпеки ми працюємо тільки
по Білій лінії з кожної сторони по
команді раз два три ви починаєте в
довільному порядку бігати а наші е-е
хитрі лисички Вони намагаються забрати
хвостик стоп стоп гра не почалась як
тільки гості було забрано ролями ви міня
тобто в кого хвостик забраний лисичка
його собі чіпляє і нова хитра лисичка в
нас з'явилася ви готові
давайте раз два три почали
але рухатися обов'язково обов'язково
мова рухатися по майданчику
Не забувайте умову як є У нас є
обмеження лінії
і стоп стоп І будь ласка залишили всі на
своїх місцях приготували долоні і ми
зараз з вами зробимо певну вправу на
відновлення і рахуємо раз два три чотири
п'ять шість сім вісім і просто самі собі
поаплодували
Дякую і я вам хочу запропонувати пограти
далі гра пішла граємо
[оплески]
ще одна локація перед нами
з'явилася на екрані нагадаю внизу
ліворуч кіберфутбол праворуч Марія Глоба
на чолі і наші колеги наші освітяни які
засвоюють вчаться практикують модель
уроку №2 і
зверху вже ми бачимо на екрані з'явився
колега Ігор з м'ячем я я знаю про що
зараз буде йти мова Я обожнюю Кажу чесно
і знаю що ви так само дуже-дужете
ці ігри цей драйв Це просто Шалені
емоції Шквал вир тоді коли столиця
України просто гуде на всю Україну і не
лише тому що є і всесвітній cool games
так Ігоре про це я говорю я просто бачу
запал твоїх очах
та футбол тому не зміг пройти повз м'яч
власне Ми щойно були на кіберспорті і
хлопці ті хлопці які грали там в Фіфу
вони грають перш за все в такий реальний
футбол і вони обожнюють грати і я
обожнюю не так вправно граю як вони але
може якщо що забити нашому супер-кіперу
чи може не вдасться давай повторимо на
біс Так
це найбільший голкіпер в історії
оператор Ти готовий ми візьме у ворота і
я спробую парашутиком
Вау так Це гол і сьогодні наші Кіпр
футболісти ще сюди повернуться
обов'язково Ну а ми прийшли сюди на
локацію наших улюблених
coolgems Привіт друзі
Вітаю вас Ну що ж cool games - Це дійсно
наше українське надбання і наше дідуся
якими ми так пишаємось давайте всі п'ять
тільки круті тільки всі спортивні всі
сучасні і звичайно право у нас тут
голкіпери це приємно Ну що ж І сьогодні
тут в нас відбувається такий невеличкий
приклад того як ідуть ігри cool games
звісно cool games - це спортивні
естафети які були винайдено саме в
Україні це так би мовити знаєте діти ще
в комітетах фізичного виховання та
спорту Міністерства освіти і науки
України і подивіться це виглядає
настільки просто але просто Це тільки у
їхньому виконанні у виконанні супер
спортсменів Але в той же час а я
зрозумів тепер Чому в нього є
рукавиці тому що він не тільки вміє
відбивати пенальті але Ось з такими
здоровенними м'ячами обов'язково
справляється і вони впораються Я навіть
не маю в цьому сумнівів так само дійсно
як вже сказала сьогодні Катя те що cool
games - це те що люблять всі і дорослі і
діти звичайно ми всі знаємо наскільки
cool games люблять в Україні і вже не
тільки знаєте грають на районних міських
обласних та навіть загального
національних чемпіонатах School Games
але навіть міжнародний cool games
відбувався в Україні в Києві і тепер
коли різні збірні приїхали сюди до нас
Вони знаєте у хорошому сенсі цього слова
цей спортивний вірус українських cool
games несуть далі від Казахстану і Китая
до Хорватії Грузії Сербії і Молдови і
багатьох багатьох ще країн і знаєте
світ хотів би щоб винайшли десь це вони
але ні cool games винайшли в Україні і
за кілька років cool games розширилась
настільки що сьогодні десятки і навіть
сотні тисяч українців українських учнів
школярів на уроках фізкультури грають
всі рухливі естафети Ну що ж ми зараз
можемо запитати в наших суддів і
наставників
так А можете пояснити сюди в мікрофон
Так що будуть відбуватися що ви радите
Підійдіть ближче трохи дистанція
проводиться не
нашкодить не на швидкість
такої можна сказати навіть на естафету а
всією командою вони будуть стрибати і
відповідно хто довше прострибує той і
переможе це неможливо прогавити тому
спостерігаємо разом
Ну а поки ви ми поки ми спостерігаємо за
cool games Хто брав участь і був
присутній на cool games згадаю Одразу я
трошечки розкажу таку інформацію надам
поки ми спостерігаємо що в cool games
програма активності включає
22 інноваційні естафети і рухливі
командні ігри та культурну частини
презентація командами своїх регіонів
участь у рухових активностях за
вподобаннями це тематичні квести
відвідування басейну настільні ігри І
дійсно вже з практичної точки зору з
того що ми бачили і відчували коли були
в моменті що під час змагань да Спочатку
це тренувальні змагання де діти
тренуються проходять естафети до яких
Вони готувалися
далі йдуть відбіркові ігри фінал Але
після Ігор не закінчується cool games
School Game продовжується тому що діти
мають змогу відвідувати різноманітні
квести
прогулянки містом басейн настільні ігри
і рухливі ігри І дійсно настільки Вони
е-е
стають друзями да звісно що вони
обмінюються акаунтами в Інстаграмі
ті хтоці Але що ми помічаємо постійно що
Україна об'єднується завдяки Ось таким
cool games і це насправді це настільки
круто що наші з вами діти наші з вами
учні та учениці
беручи участь у cool games потім дружать
вже не просто так а вони приїжджають
свої школи вони розказують щоб вони
познайомилися з
учнями Да з однолітками з Тернополя
Чернівців з Києва з Черкас з Ужгорода з
Мукачева тощо і починається Ось так наша
країна об'єднується ще і ще раз
настільки наскільки круто і потім коли
кожна команда кожен регіон презентує
свій регіон свої свій колорит ми
впізнаємо вже і по музиці порухав І
потребуту що це за регіон Чи це
Одеса та Перлина біля моря Чи це
Полтавщина з відомими
всім Чи це західна Україна і Львів як це
культурна столиця все зрозуміло Все
настільки порідне по рідному і об'єднує
Дітей ну і звісно що вчителі в колег які
привозять цих дітей які беруть участь
які є головними суддями на е-е cool
games тому що не не має сторонніх осіб
всі як одна Велика сім'я тут і зараз всі
грають всі відпочивають і останній вечір
Як правило да февел паті де ми
зустрічаємося ще раз командами з друзями
з дітьми з усіма організаторами і тут
окрім ось таких е-е слів задоволення
радості сміху щастя є ще сльози сльози
трошечки такої грусті що ми всі
розстаємося але повертаємося далі Ну що
давайте послухаємо
по команді стартує
і
ложать ягоди в гніздечко це потім
обертає Мартер розвороту маркера звороту
і перейде передає естафету наступному
учаснику
далі наступний учасник
складаю кошик але є така штука що можна
тримати тільки два м'ячика в одній руці
на більше
і Так же само передає естафету далі по
колу
Дякуємо дійсно як бачимо все просто але
головне не заплутеся не заплутатися і не
махлювати друзі все по-чесному має бути
правильно нам лусказано що не треба
брати по декілька одразу ягід ну В нас
зараз сезон літа сезон ягід але ми
використовуємо м'ячі цей для гігієни і
Для зручності звісно і бачимо зараз
наступний челендж наступний етап cool
games
і поїхали наші
атлети
молоді спортсмени і спортсменки знаєте
немов в українських казках йшла Червона
шапочка або ж летіла Принцеса Лебідь там
ящики лишала по собі а далі їх збирала
Ну звісно в нас сучасна так а от тут
треба дуже важливо не купити
м'ячів не губити ягідки і все вправно
тримати Тобто ми бачимо що це завдання
Воно не тільки на швидкість А ще воно
дуже і дуже підступне тому що треба
влучити і бачимо не можна просто кинути
м'яч тому що він не потрапить у лунку не
потрапить в це гніздечко Ну і важливо
тому хто розкладав не збирати ягоди як
бачимо вже наступний учасник команди
партнер і має забирати я
непогано в нас ідуть обидві команди але
ж хто стане переможцем ось питання Ну
давайте вперед друзі
Ось так вирішили останні метри в рівній
боротьбі
тут трошечки така поправка у нас було
сім учасників тому у нас
в той учасник Котрий із пустою корзинкою
тобто повинна бути або шість або вісім
зрозуміло всім
дякую
Спасибі величезне надзвичайні круті
хлопці і дівчата
Ну що ви заснули чи втомилися чи
спекотно
спекотно а ти не перевіримо наскільки
вище не спите Слава Україні
[музика]
Слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
Ось бачите бадьорів потужність спортивні
і спека їх не злякає викруті хлопці
Дівчата а ми School Game зараз йдемо на
ще одна така естафета активність ігри
курейси які зазначу як сказав Ігор це
вже студентське змагання тобто змагання
в яких беруть участь всі студенти з
різних регіонах України
теж
вони спрямовані на поєднання такої
рухової активності з
заохоченням дітей
вже да студентів до
і креативу і творчості тому що знову ж
таки це триває декілька днів
знайомства нові але знаєте Якщо
порівняти ігри студентські і шкільні то
я думаю що ви зі мною погодитеся що вони
відрізняються хоча наче і естафети і там
і там але все-таки до студентів ми вже
ставимося як до дорослих особистостей Ну
і чесно кажучи
завдання у них вже такі не дитячі Якщо
так говорити
завдання важкі вони не лише на швидкість
да як так може бути оскільки це кулерист
вони на все вони нас спритність вони на
координацію на
врівноваження що часто вгамувати емоції
які вирують а вони вони там дуже-дуже
вирують І дійсно ці от під час цих
змагань вони виконуються там на
швидкість зараховується е-е
хвилини виконання хвилини секунди завжди
йде електронний підрахунок
результатів учасників тому не може бути
потім під питань що хтось щось там
неправильно порахував або що тому що
завжди є електронний підрахунок голосів
стоять камери і все можна подивитися
весь процес все це
зрозуміло для кожного Cool рейс цікава
ініціатива і естафета діяльність можна
говорити по-різному але дійсно це те що
об'єднує вже студентів і вже Спілкуючись
з учасниками Колись ми розуміємо що Ну
вони приїхали сюди знаєте Не для Не для
того щоб поставити галочку да а для того
щоб дійсно взяти участь Тому що це
цікаво А якщо молоді нашій цікаво то це
звісно говорить про те що ми робимо з
вами правильно все ми робимо те що
потрібно ми на правильній дорозі і далі
далі можемо
рухатися в цьому ж напрямку власне що і
робимо і ми і ми піде відео Міністерства
освіти науки України містечко спорту
України комітету фізичного виховання та
спорту Ось так перед нами зараз
модель року
фізичної культури №2
як ми вже говорили Марія Глоба
навчає заохочує мотивує і дещо розважає
своїх колег урок ще триває можемо з вами
бути трошечки поспостерігати що тут
відбувається бачимо що настрій у всіх
гарний
веселий всі задіяні всі рухаються всі
беруть участь всі пробують ці вправи Ну
я думаю що Зрозуміло Зрозуміло Що зараз
відбувається дуже просто споглядаючи на
екран і беремо собі на заміточку теж
деякі
вправи які які представлені Зараз перед
нами бачимо що
звісно ще уроки для
учнів та учениць навчальних закладів але
і дорослим людям теж цікаво і це
найголовніше
є Перемоги особисті у Дмитра
так і стоп
підніміть будь ласка руку тих хто
задоволений своїм своїм невеличкою
перемогою над своїми такими особистими
досягненнями і я вас вітаю з тим бо це
дуже-дуже важливо
А давайте ми піднімемо руки ті хто
задоволений емоціями ваших своєї пари
партнера команди давайте привітаємо один
одного
і це є Здорово так і зараз мені треба
допомога усіх нас давайте приберемо з
серединки весь цей інвентар але
поставимо його так щоб він нам трошки не
заважав
Дякую
якраз у нас спільна команда така спільна
командна робота по прибиранню нашої
інвентарю
і Наступне Що у нас хочеться вам
запропонувати це об'єднатися в дві
команди
давайте раз два три дві команди байдуже
одна команда шокується Тут друга команда
тут
але мені треба так щоб було
більш-менш однакова кількість Давайте
порахуємо трошки математичних своїх
здібностей врахуємо
Дякую нам допомагаєш вирішити це питання
і одразу
пропоную зробити коло з цього боку і
пропоную зробити коло з цього боку
так і Наступне Що ж ми будемо робити а
будемо ми з вами грати в Dodge Bob Я
хочу зразу вам сказати що його можна
грати в колі і скажіть будь ласка хто в
нас сміливий в кожній команді Хто хоче
одразу побути
в ролі центрового мені треба дві
раз і швидко бажання
двоє двоє двоє все два І у вас
є два Так звичайно хочеться вашого
ширшого кола трошечки ширшого і вашого
ширшого помітити собі очима де ви тут
стоїте щоб ви контролювали і за
правилами гри в дочволі в колі ми граємо
наступне завдання того кого м'яч попасти
той хто всерединці в кого попали ви
міняєтесь місцями і звичайно мета
пробути тут як можна довше а мета того
хто стоїть у нас назовні то як можна
більше кількості вибити суперників
правила зрозуміло
все починаємо гра пішла
Я хочу обумовити за технікою безпеки
ногами м'ячі не подаємо
нарешті відпочиваю разом з усіма
учасниками нашої надзвичайної
конференції то ви помиляєтесь тому що
тут це дуже-дуже серйозно це
Cool Race і локація найкрутіших забігів
для студентської молоді ну Сьогодні ми
сюди і учнівську молодь залучаємо це теж
ноу-хаус саме наше українське розроблене
комітетом фізичного виховання та спорту
Міністерства освіти і науки України а і
Наскільки я розумію красиві дівчата в
комплекті не йдуть Але ми їх тут знайшли
дівчата йдіть ближче до мене Що ви що ви
так далеко стоїте Давайте ми для
глядачів сьогодні у вас назву
представимось
Ганна і Наталя взагалі не спекотно вам
чи ви самі настільки стильні і гарячі що
цю спеку переносити легко
А ще гарячі стають коли тут відбувається
забіги ось такий він Cool рейс Дівчатка
ви тут будете спостерігати щоб все було
за правилами так щоб хлопці коли бігли і
задивлялися не на вас а прямо і до
фінішу Так в нас тут є Я так розумію вже
команда чемпіонів Ходімо зараз покажемо
їх ого Тут дуже серйозний в нас десант
проїзд хлопці і дівчата Як настрій
вони нормально Окей Йосиф тільки що
сказали а як ви готові перемагати
опять да все нормально ну що ж тепер
Краще нам трішечки відійти від цього бо
тут буде все дуже і дуже гаряче
насправді вже на вднг в нас у Києві
відбувалися забіги School рейс в них
брали участь українські студенти і
тільки завдяки трекерам а тут все
серйозно могли дізнатися хто ж стане
переможцем і Я впевнений що навіть Ось
ця Юна Ліга оця молодь яка підростає вже
для того щоб теж брати участь
студентських колдрейс вже навіть на
такому пробному уроці фізкультури покаже
На що вони здатні Ну що дівчата дасте їм
команду
готові Ну що я тоді рахую до трьох і
починаємо один два три почали
Подивіться подивіться
яка пристрасть яка йде напруга і головне
тут не травмувати себе чи свого
супротивника давай давай давай давай
давай давай ти зможеш
Молодчинка змогла пройти
Ось так цю смугу перешкод а Подивіться
на фініші це ж просто Люди в чорному не
лячно Коли така малеча позаду яка може й
знести ні все добре під контролем все
добре Все під контролем так так так так
так так і ще один у нас фінішер Чудово
Так як бачимо в нас триває забіг наше
поважне журі оно слідкує щоб все було
все було чесно і звичайно щоб все було
без травм і зайвої небезпеки ви
розумієте що тут серйозний інвентар
серйозні перешкоди дійсно
для дуже маленьких спортсменів це ще
зарано для них є cool games А ось тих
хто стають вже старшими потужнішими і
хочуть щось серйозніше то можна себе
випробувати наших надзвичайних смугах
перешкод під назвою кури своє красиво
проходить він просто перестрибнув щойно
і ще один фініш молодці
Так в нас одна перешкода була збита але
не треба втрачати Надії давай давай
давай ти зможеш ти зможеш ще трішечки і
Ну що ж чудовий виступи у нас там там
всі пробігли чи ще в нас є всі клас Ну
що ж друзі зараз ви побачили як просто
взагалі так само навіть до Cool Race
який на перший погляд виглядають як ну
просто армійська слуга перешкод ще
тільки знаєте наші україночки Українці
які в лавах Збройних Сил України служить
може тій пройти ні всі українці можуть і
юні і маленькі тому друзі ми дуже
дякуємо Це було дуже потужно і дуже
гаряче ну справді знаєте серйозно самі
бігали кол рейс
тобто в нас буде
що дівчатка і хлопці дівчатка буде такий
в нас показовий забіг давай налаштуємо
можна можна робити все повільно і
красиво дві дівчинки спробуємо
Ну що Ганна і Наталя Як то кажуть на біс
Ну що зараз буде по-справжньому гаряче
я дам команду на три Да що 1 2 3 поїхали
Наталі
Ганна Ганна Ганна Ганна
Наталя давай Наталка до зможеш давай ще
трохи але все ж таки
гарна була трішечки раніше тут хоча ще
добігти треба
Ось так бачите в нас ще і наші запальні
судді теж можуть пробігти А це правильно
щоб не кричати там суддю на мило судді
теж знають що це таке там у дівчата
молодці це було круто а тож всім раджу
спробувати теж
кул рейс на А ми побіжимо далі і можливо
навіть
навіть можливо Cool рейс
дійсно Це звісно не застрягнув обережно
Ігор ти нам ще потрібен далі у тебе ще
багато локацій є попереду ну а до речі
щойно судді наші пробували А на і
Наталія свої сили в кулерець Я пам'ятаю
по завершенню курейс коли вже був
відомий були відомі переможці ми вже
привітали студентів та студенток далі
організатори цієї такої
божевільної події під назвою курейси
мали змогу і вони нею скористалися вони
бігли всі ці естафети Про що ми говорили
що самі придумали самі спробуйте на себе
і було дуже цікаво і дійсно це говорить
про те що в cool games став Cool raze
беруть участь не е-е люди які займаються
спортом є спортсменами
легкоатлетами там я не знаю тобто вони
самостійно тренуються Ні це посередній
українець посередній український студент
або студентка які зможуть виконати Ось
такі вправи вони да вони нелегкі звісно
але й вони абсолютно доступні для того
щоб їх виконати тому що ми і
переконалися тоді на собі разом з
колегами разом з організаторами комітету
фізичного виховання та спорту що в це
абсолютно реально І абсолютно реально
зробити ці дистанції тому
долучайтеся якщо ви раптом прогавили
Минулого року Ми віримо в те що
дуже-дуже скоро ми зможемо зустрічатися
з усіма офлайн і проводити ось ці
неймовірно класні спортивні заходи
на повернулися ми як ви пам'ятаєте до
уроку
який проводить Марія Глоба
урок модель уроку фізичної культури №2
Це був
загальний фізична підготовка Вона має
бути на кожному уроці вона не являється
окремо модулями Тобто це і є та незмінна
інваріативна складова яка має бути
обов'язково Ну а тепер я пропоную
зробити
маленькі такий феєрверк наших гостинок і
загальне фото на пам'ять
ура
вітаємо Марію і вчителів освітян з
завершенням моделі Урок фізичної
культури №2 бачимо Що вже йде
традиційне мабуть вже для всіх нас з
вами Ось таке колективне фото про те що
ще один етап пройденого нашої сумісної з
вами онлайн і офлайн робота ми будемо з
вами рухатися і вже рухаємося далі хочу
нагадати що ж сьогодні відбувалося
з того що було тут активне Да ми були з
вами учасниками змагань cool games
кіберфутболу Cool рейс ось власне щойно
дивилися
спостерігали за проведенням уроку
від Марії глоби І
далі далі будемо буде Ага ще у нас були
віари да пам'ятаєте що трошечки ми Ігора
попросили на собі спробувати і У нього
дуже класно До речі вийшло Я не рішилася
кажу вам чесно я спустилася як обіцяла
але участі поки ще не взяла
пам'ятаємо про те що відбулися вже
практично тренувальні заходи з
евакуацією учасників освітнього процесу
у разі загрози бо виникнення
надзвичайних ситуацій на території
закладу освіти
проводив Вадим Ткаченко полковник служби
цивільного захисту заступника начальника
управління начальник відділу запобігання
надзвичайним ситуаціям та заходів до
нього запиту Дніпровського ДСНС України
у Києві було Теж ми шуткували Да який
час такі конкурси Але щоб не кажи ми
маємо в першу чергу ми дорослі
відповідальні за безпеку і свою і дітей
які поруч з нами навчаються і на уроці
це реалії сьогодення і від них ми поки
що не можемо піти тому сприймаємо все
так як є і головне навчатися бути
готовими і морально
пам'ятаєте Да що ми з вами також
дивилися спостерігали за футболом
кіберфутбол це гра FIFA тут наразі
грають дві українські команди Це я
дивлюся вже на табло один гол є тут
і спробували хлопці Ну звісно да
комп'ютерні ігри як би ми не нарікали
дорослі на них Але вони стали просто
невід'ємною частиною нашого життя і це
знову ж таки ті реалії які треба
приймати да наші діти учні онуки сидять
в там планшетах телефонах той що грають
Ну а що робити це ми також з вами
погодьтеся дорослі
частенько залипаємо Facebook новини або
Telegram Тому від цього нікуди нам не
дітися А якщо діти приводять час граючи
у футбол тобто
вони знають всіх команди за які вони
грають всі ми чули сьогодні прізвище
наших українських футболістів яких
просто ну навіть люди які не знають і не
дивляться футбол Я впевнена що вони чули
такі прізвища як Ярмоленко ну його
неможливо просто не знати класно як
варіант дозвілля тому що зараз наприклад
ну важко сказати що можна ходити Да в
дитячі кімнати розважальні майданчики
кінотеатри Ну мені якщо чесно як мамі
трошечки Ну лячно я це не роблю Кажу
чесно відверто не знаю кожного своя
думка з приводу цього мені поки що
здається що це ну можна заохочувати
іншим то окрім того щоб з дітьми бігати
там зранку займатися спортом тому що до
цього теж потрібно привчати інколи все ж
таки з лімітом Family Link Хто не знає
цей додаток пишіть мені в особисті я
обов'язково поділюся і все-таки можна
давати трошечки часу пограти і у
Ось такі ігри футбол ну цікаво Я не знаю
мені Як для жінки то я дивлюся і ми її
просто подобається ця гра тому що гарно
промальовано якісна Да не треба там
напружувати зошит щоб щось роздивитися
навіть
гравці які беруть у яких грають тут на
полі їх можна впізнати оце взагалі супер
Я кажу це можливо можливо для вас це не
новина ФІФА і хтось вже давно пройшов
всі рівні і виграв уже всіх Я дивлюся
Чесно кажучи її Сьогодні вперше чула про
неї але власне що побачила я її вперше І
дійсно Я розумію що це дуже ну класно
круто да можна можна може бути і головне
що це про спорт а не про ці стрілялки
які ми теж разом з вами не любимо тому
краще нехай комп'ютерні ігри будуть про
спорт і тоді тоді все буде круто так
пам'ята
те що у нас вже були корейську Games
дуже хочеться таке особисте дуже
хочеться зустрітися з усіма пам'ятаєте в
наші офлайн да заходи коли всі разом
Коли ми вболівали коли ми проводили
іранкові зустрічі і вечірні зустрічі і
разом грали перемагали дітей просто всіх
обійняти сказати що нарешті ми тут з
вами вірю Особисто я вірю що скоро це
буде наша перемога вже ми її наближуємо
віримо в Україну віримо в зсуву а вони
хлопці та дівчата роблять все можливе і
часом неможливе є для того щоб перемога
була наша Так це наші Супергерої ніякі
не Марвел не Капітан Америка там чи
людина-павук А це наші звичайні хлопці
та дівчата які боронять нас І завдяки
яким ми сьогодні з вами Ось так онлайн і
офлайн зустрі
спілкуємося навчаємося
переймаємо досвід один одного і просто
Класно гарно проводимо час ну і знову ж
таки я повторюся і скажу про те що спорт
дійсно об'єднує нас і клас Так завтра
Зараз у нас ще по плану трошечки зробити
таке невеличке оголошення Я думаю що ви
знайомі з програмою але все-таки що що
загубилося що ще ми плануємо У нас ще є
авторські майстер-класи по плану
скоро вони так само мають бути ми про це
обов'язково скажемо це марафон освітніх
практик вчителі фізичної культури модель
онлайн уроку фізичної культури за
модельною навчальною програмою для
різних форм навчання тобто дистанційна
очна індивідуальна сімейна екстерна в
тому числі для дітей які знаходяться за
кордоном що є дуже актуальним зараз
завданням на часі Зараз воно актуальне з
березня будемо говорити так ну все-таки
теж чому варто повчитися послухати і
взяти до уваги і застосовувати
авторський майстер-класи з варіативних
модулів навчальних програм для різних
рівнів освіти ось таке у нас по плану ще
по плану є сквош волейбол і Падал теніс
про що ми ми обов'язково трошечки згодом
анонсуємо Коли це буде коли ми будемо з
вами теж спостерігати дивитися вчитися
До речі у нас ще є і буде обов'язково
майстер-клас з проведення квест-уроку
Ось так теж дуже цікаве
нове нове таке направлення да
застосування тому
тому будемо спостерігати
Так Якраз
[музика]
квест урок цікаво будемо спостерігати До
речі як я квестом закінчую а власне
скоро буде ним починати Я ігор тому що
дуже скоро ми вже готуємося до
проведення цього квестру року декілька
хвилиночок і будемо говорити Ну а поки
що ми ще можемо
спостерігати поспостерігати за
українськими командами які А ось тут
українська українська команда 1:0 яка
українська команда перемагає невідома
головне ж українська команда перемагає
правильно Ну я думаю що тут взагалі
зараз
несуть важливо назва команди звіт о один
один ні Чи я бачите мене теж захоплює це
все я з мене звісно крокоментатор
футболу Так собі будемо казати чесно
ігор по справився з цим набагато краще
за мене тому що він коментує футбольні
змагання і все-таки трошечки я вже з
свого погляду може говорити але лікар не
може це робити зараз тому що він на
іншій локації про яку ми будемо говорити
Вже дуже-дуже скоро Ось так хоча б Я
знаю що він би
аби аби йому не потрібно було йти на
коли рейс і на квест урок він би зараз
отам сидів доставив би собі третє крісло
і тоді би поряд з дітьми і спостерігав
за грою футбол це такий невеличкий
секретик про колегу я вам розкажу футбол
це як то кажуть його життя
так друзі говорила про
квеструк Зараз ми його Чет чекаємо скоро
Він буде скоро Він з'явиться на наших
екранах і будемо разом з вами далі
дивитися що ж там відбувається
[музика]
вже третій підтягнувся Дивіться що що
відбувається
жовті десь на ти знайшли якісь інші
кнопки
почали грати зовсім по-іншому
не можна віддавати будинок і рахунок
стає нічим ви бачите
хлопці це дуже потужна партія діти
загубилися в лабіринті все добре Це дуже
спеціально навчені діти і це ніякий не
Лабіринт до Лабіринт звісно але це перш
за все квест і я навіть скажу більше
друзі це спортивне орієнтування саме Ось
так загартовуються і карбуються більше
того навіть майбутнє чемпіони
чемпіонатів Європи світу України перш за
все і навіть Олімпійських ігор все
починається ось з таких лабіринтів
завдяки в тому числі як у нас є
професіонали в навчальному комплексі
Домінанта які дозволяють дітям по-перше
знаєте опанувати навіть легку тож
атлетику і для того щоб орієнтуватися на
місцевості тому що ми повністю говорити
так про топографічний креатиніст так би
мовити мовляв це Ера Google Maps телефон
дістав і пішов власне про гаджети тут
теж є тому що діти не просто знаєте
збирають якісь наліпки а тут є
спеціальні трекери і бачимо діти
натискають ось зараз подивіться Так там
є звуковий сигнал і пішли далі І також у
них є мапа чудова справилися між іншим
вітаємо але я думаю ще краще нам про це
розкажуть безпосередньо наші
професіонали нашого квесту який створили
зараз у нас ми бачимо отримують легенду
так мапу так пан Максим в нас якраз
зараз роздає все що чекає на них
так не хочеться просто заважати зараз
нашим майбутнім чемпіоном Ми дивимось як
вони отримують свої
трекери Вони отримують чіпи і отримують
мапи
як тут не заплутатись Максим вітаю
Вітаю вас як не заплутатись у цьому Ми
тут дивимось зараз глядачами і не
розуміємо діти просто блукають
лабіринтом а потім ні вони виходять вони
натискають на чіпси в них дається як Ну
не знаю треба звичайно дуже багато
практикуватися для того щоб мати певні
навички але на початку Всім дуже цікаво
навіть дорослим тож долучайтеся
Приходьте приводьте дітей і всі разом
шукайте свою пригоду а правда що ось з
такої мале чи з таких стартових навіть
не змагальних А ось так для фану для
задоволення для спортивного да ну
підійди сюди розповідай давай давай ні
все все вже вийшов Ну можете підходить
ми тебе самі знайдемо Як тебе звуть
крута зачіска хто зробив батьки чи
барбершопі
батьки а хто тато чимало
а вони вдвох да мама з одного боку у
тата з другого типу тепер зрозумів Ти
давно взагалі береш участь таких квестах
спортивного орієнтування
Круто тобі вже вдалось вийти Чи ти ще не
спробував давай в тебе все обов'язково
вийде а і ось з таких от ростиків та які
посміхаються вперше лише можуть
спробувати і зрештою можуть вирости
чемпіони тому що наскільки я пам'ятаю
спортивне орієнтування в світі на дуже
високому рівні навіть там і серед
олімпійців серед там на чемпіонатах
світу Європи а серед паралімпійців
дефлімпійців на дефлімпійських іграх в
Україні взагалі не було рівних навесні в
Бразилії То тобто і ось такого віку
можуть вирости справжнім чемпіони
тримайте мікрофон
Так дякую звичайно звичайно саме змалку
і вирощується чемпіони дійсно Як каже
Мій товариш що
буквально досить небагато часу тому було
проведено змагання міжнародні змагання в
Бразилії по дефоліпійським іграм де наші
спортсмени були дійсно неперевершені
були так
[музика]
просто супер виступили таким чином що по
троє спортсменів були на п'єдесталі
тобто
вирощуючись з малечі і надалі надалі але
можна долучатися будучи і більш дорослим
тому всіх Запрошуємо спробувати точно
треба
Дякуємо максимум Ми сьогодні теж
спробуємо Наскільки я розумію то навіть
кілька типів так буде тут із спортивного
орієнтування квести в лабіринті А можна
попросити мапу я хочу просто показати
глядачам щоб не думали знаєте що це
жарти ось Максим згадав про дефлімпіаду
в КС досулу в Бразилії дефлімпіади 2022
і не просто знаєте ми круто виступили ми
стали першими з усіх видів спорту в
загальнокомандному рейтингу і це сталося
в тому числі завдяки спортивному
орієнтуванні Господи слухайте як тут
можна щось зрозуміти так то ти Лабіринт
Спробуй пройти сам по собі а ще коли
Подивіться відмітки позначки і вдається
Ну звичайно дійсно ми маємо мапу на якій
маємо позначки це Все До речі що
потрібно для того щоб пройти дистанцію
перший пункт у нас позначений
трикутничком це Стар орієнтування і
останній пункт подвійним кружечком це
фініш орієнтоване орієнтування Отже Ми
маємо по порядочку зібрати пункти від
першого до останнього і фінішувати після
цього ідея у нас електронна щітка ми
можемо отримати одразу в онлайн
результаті кожен свій номер за яким ми
фінішували ну і відповідно Таким чином
Ми
визначаємо переможців тобто від першого
до останнього місця Ну і можна проводити
Таким чином як тестові завдання як
просто змагання або ж можна проводити
змагання на результат і вже проводити
саме нагородження
ну це дійсно вражає враховуючи що тут не
просто знаєте крок за кроком 1-2 а вони
знаходяться в різних куточках лабіринту
і це справді вражає окрім того наскільки
я розумію ця система вона в принципі
дублює ту яка є на професійних змаганнях
Можливо там в надзвичайно більш така
якась серйозна складна але так для дітей
Ну це надзвичайно щоб вони вже можуть
спробувати не просто наліпки збирати А
ось так натискати і проходити весь
Лабіринт дійсно система аналогічна
повністю ті яка проводиться на
міжнародних змаганнях Тому все реально і
все по-справжньому і як його вже сказав
що ми маємо зараз другу локацію тобто
перше - це у нас лабіринт і друга це
буде мапа на якій буде позначено
територію нашої школи і діти мають в
такому ж порядку зібрати свої пункти і
прибігти на фініш
Ого тобто в нас все стає надто серйозно
Ну ви уявіть бачите Лабіринт не просто
діти блукали але виходили а тепер я
попрошу нашого розкішного оператора
показати і навчально-виховний комплекс
Домінанта який позаду мене ви ж
розумієте ми вже другий день Тут були і
в актовій залі і на вулицю на стадіоні і
бачили як під'їздили сюди пожежні машини
від ДСНС України і зал всередині це до
речі не один зал який там є там є ще
великий і уявіть вся ця площа це мапа
для спортивного орієнтування і тому я
розумію що цій малечі але серйозність
спортивній українській учнівський молоді
Їм Зараз буде не просто але я навіть не
маю сумнів що вони впораються Отож
будемо спостерігати І звісно Ідемо далі
так з цікаво погодьтеся Да дуже цікаво
спортивно-орієнтування квест і
це не нове для дітей тому що вони ж
зараз дуже багато квест кімнат і дуже
багато дітей
вже відвідували різноманітні квести вони
є і спортивні вони є там і містичні і
трошки лячні різні вже вподобання від
себе але мозок дітей працює Ну на мою
думку набагато швидше за
дорослих по своєму досвіду можу сказати
що коли Ми відвідували квесту наша
дитина якось їм це ближче от дійсно їм
це ближче їм це швидше поки ми там
роздивлялися мапу він пройшов вже
половину тому квест - Це дуже цікаво Це
дуже цікаво Це дуже мотивуюче це
розвиває і
логіку і креатив і
інтелект І звісно ми говоримо про
фізкультуру то по фізичну культуру
фізичне виховання виховує дітей фізично
активними фізично дієвими фізично
здоровими це дуже-дуже важливо бачимо
зараз я ко Територія А дітки пробують
далі свої сили у на різних точках так на
різних локаціях їм пояснюють Вони все
виконують тобто для проходження певної
локації потрібні необхідні гаджети
необхідні речі Вони це все здобувають
знову ж таки і швидко рухаючись І звісно
своїм розумом Ось так у нас тут
з'явилося ще одне поле вікно Ми бачимо
що продовжується уроки продовжується
моделлю модель Точніше да уроків
продовжується навчання для наших колег
для наших вчителів тому у нас якраз з
вами є така можливість побувати всюди
подивитися і на орієнтування подивитися
і на навчання користуємося цією
можливістю і дивимося далі що Що
відбувається на наших екранах
так дуже У нас багато всього цікавого
друзі ми зависли я в класному сенсі
цього слова хочу сказати на спортивному
орієнтуванні дей і Лабіринти як ми вже
анонсували скоро почнеться справжній
квест Ну і я звичайно захоплююсь спортом
високих досягнень Як і всі українці
вболіваємо за наших але варто ж говорити
про те що чемпіони вони ростуть ось з
такого так з садочку зі школи в дорослих
атлетів і звісно не всі з них стануть ну
далеко переважно велика-велика меншість
стане професійними спортсменами А
головне щоб не стануть чемпіонами у
своєму житті обов'язково будуть
прославляти нашу країну в усіх сферах
життя так от ось подібне спортивне
орієнтування такі квести вони дуже
будуть корисними як у уроках і фізичного
виховання і не лише у школах так тобто
вивчити свою школу вивчити свій край
можна це включати різні квести квизи
опитування Так там з математики з
історії України географії Та хоч
літератури і це буде дійсно цікаво Тобто
будуть діти краще орієнтуватися на
місцевості будуть рухатися спорт в цей і
рухова активність теж включені дуже-дуже
потужно Ну і звичайно думати своїми е
також міськами своєю свідомістю
розвивати також свої голівоньки но ми
йдемо далі в нас в спортивному залі буде
дуже цікавий урок модель уроку фізичного
виховання фізичної культури ми не
пропускаємо тим більше підготували наші
вчителі які вчора бігали як спортсмени
як діти самі на уроках тепер вже вони
нам покажуть що ж вони вивчили і головне
що вони можуть запропонувати нам
українським освітянам і головне і
дітлахам нашим школярам нашим
українському майбутньому Ходімо разом
Ну а ми вже з вами тут не треба нікуди
йти ми вже з вами вірту віртуозна і
віртуально
перемістилися на цей урок і можемо
спостерігати
спостерігати за тим що відбувається
власне спостерігати за колегами та
навчанням за моделлю уроку
ємося
беремося за руки Так Залишаємо один
м'ячик на всіх
так
ні в парах парах стаємо по парах і
Тримай за руки
те ж саме завдання що на початку уроку
Але зараз в парах готові
поїхали
добре обережно завершили будь ласка
право чотири будь ласка на цю половину
майданчика стала 4 на цю
в колону по одному
Так
у нас тут уявна сітка буде пограємо у
теніс з м'ячем
грає так весь майданчик ваше завдання
двома руками зверху або знизу перебитий
м'ячик на сторону опонентів можете чітко
на них грати А можете десь в сторону ви
ви перебігаєте на та по праву руку так
граємо до 5 добре
так В кого В кого більше двох
в кого більше двох помилок той вибиває з
гри тобто якщо у вас м'ячик падає і вони
зробили передачу тоді виходити з гри
готові
працюємо
не ловимо
можете в будь-яку сторону не на гравця
[музика]
рахунок 3:2
молодці для спрощення цієї гри можете
використовувати
непередачі а кидки або зверху або знизу
давайте за спрощуємо Тобто ви робите
правильно постановку рук зверху або
кидок знизу як бажаєте і робите кидок
Так але м'ячик не опускаємо нижче
підборіддя
стоп стоп стоп кидаємо як зверху або
знизу просто кидаємо
м'ячик вище чола
звертайте увагу на правильну Постанову
Кору
добре може грати будь-яка частина тіла
можете в будь-яку сторону
добре збираємося на центрі майданчика
А тепер Давайте до нашого майстер-класу
долучимо такий модуль як дочку він теж
грається волейбольним м'ячем давайте на
рівні команди розподілилося 4х4 ваше
завдання
граємо давайте
ще три м'ячі будь ласка
м'ячі встановлюються на середині Поля ви
йдете на лицеву лінію волейбольного
майданчика ви на лицеву лінію
волейбольного майданчика шикуйтесь
ще один м'яч будь ласка
ваше завдання
по команді по 321 Dodge Ball ви
рухаєтеся якнайшвидшень м'ячі
Ви маєте вийти один раз вийти за
триметрову лінію ви з цієї сторони Ви з
цієї сторони далі ваше завдання
якнайшвидше вибити гравця одного другого
або третього або четвертого одне правило
перше
основне не Заходите за середину поля раз
і не виходити за межі волейбольного
майданчика
цілите в голову не можна
цілите в тіло
готові три два один дощ Бог
від землі не рахується
від землі нарахується
можна хто зловив м'яч має додаткове
життя Прошу добре від землі нарахується
якщо команда зловила м'яч ви можете
свого гравця знову запустити на поле
Ох ми тут зайшли а тут гаряче
справжню зарубу організацію Анатолія
вона гравець глава злапав м'яч і ви
можете вийти на поле
щось
не діється тут одночасно давайте
пробуємо одночасно атакуємо одночасно
молодці ну молодці
у відповідь молодці рухаємося рухаємося
до середини поля можна до середини поля
можна до середини поля рухатись
до середини поля можна рухатись
від землі не рахується вибитий гравець
до середини можна рухатись
так залишається півтора хвилини
добре вибили
за середину не заходити Бо це буде
порушення правил
залишається 1 хвилина
з правої сторони від мене 4 гравця зліва
45 секунд
4 2 30 секунд
3:2 Подивіться які баталії 20 секунд
залишається яка команда якої команди
гравців більше
один один гравець 3:1
10 секунд
5 4 3 2 100
молодці команда ліворуч перемогла
це було надзвичайно Дякуємо ми
Павлу і нашим супер атлетом головне
знаєте що всі живі і неушкоджені тому що
тут літало навіть в мене влучили Ну а я
коли тут всюди м'ячі і це круто такою і
має бути фізкультура завжди завзято з
азартом змаганням процесом і головне зі
спортом куди ж без нього коли абсолютно
всім спекотно і це дійсно Вау тож
продовжимо спостерігати дуже скоро в нас
буде наступний урок фізкультури
так ну що ж друзі ми з вами були
свідками волейболу та дочболу як вчилися
да е-е грати і вчилися і навчилися і
цікаве доч-бол да нагадує чимось якщо
говорити по простому
вибивний але бачимо що знову ж таки є
команди і є переможці і є переможені Так
що Якщо Ну ми з вами були свідками хочу
нагадати що волейбол це спортивна гра з
м'ячем у які дві команди змагаються на
спеціальному майданчику і розділений
сіткою ну сітку ми і гравці уявляли
волейбол є олімпійським видом спорту
існують декілька різних версій гри а
мета гри це направити м'яч над сіткою
так щоб він дотор навчався до ділянки
суперника та запобігти спробі гравців
суперника зробити те саме і для цього
команда має торкнутися до м'яча не
більше трьох разів Або можливо ще один
раз на блоку це ми говорили про волейбол
бачимо традиційний колективне фото Там
нас чекає ще сквоши падл теніс ще
майстер-класи де показові і можливість
навчитися і навчатися
учасникам
Ну що ж непогано в нас щойно все було і
красиво і подекуди навіть дещо
небезпечно як інакше Коли м'яч з великою
швидкістю летить і влучає але друзі
зараз час розчахлити ракетки і зіграти в
Падал теніс дійсно один з різновидів
тенісу вже ну не просто набирає
реальність а насправді популярний у
світі на заході в країнах Північної
Америки і Європейському Союзі в Західній
Європі але Україна не стоїть осторонь
всіх спортивних і ну лише спортивних
процесів і ми знаємо що українські
освітяни теж можуть і їм є що сказати
навіть колегам заходом і в тому числі
тому сьогодні в нас наступний наш
приклад уроку буде саме пов'язаний з
падл тенісом ми вже чули від Катерини
звичайно Ми говорили ще поговоримо про
Падал Деніс я хочу тільки сказати що
сьогодні тут ми в навчально-виховному
комплексі Домінанта разом звичайно з
комітетом фізичного виховання та спорту
Міністерства освіти і науки України
робимо все для того щоб
підтримувати всю країну А що є базою що
є фундаментом звичайно освіта звичайно
школа і звичайно те що нас навчає навчав
любити свою Україну вивчати і навчатися
але окрім того ми знаємо що треба не
тільки качати знаєте нашу свідомість наш
інтелект але і м'язи тому що здоровому
тілі здоровий дух і потрібно бути
фізично розвиненими а ми ще й дізналися
що спорт До речі допомагає і в розвитку
інтелекта і Падал теніс в тому числі є
дуже показовим видом спорту для цього
розвитку вітаю вас
не працює зараз і що ні все працює як
вас звуть Мене звати Марк дуже приємно
Марк Розкажіть будь ласка про
сьогоднішній урок і про падл теніс
сьогодні про падати ніс він
дуже становиться популярним у світі
навіть в деяких країнах перемагає теніс
за популярністю
в Україні він лише починає свій великий
пульт але Все тільки починається
сьогодні
я вам розповім про правила та
продемонструю пару ударів
[музика]
Як рахуються Дуже дякую Ми дуже за
інтегровані відправляємо вас до учнів
починайте урок А ми будемо з глядачами
піддивлятися тому що у нас вже є Марк в
нього є ракетки м'ячі і йому слово будь
ласка починається урок
в нас лише декілька ракеток тоді
я вам буду показувати і потім буду
давати ракетку кожному ви будете
пробувати пити Це дуже легко
дивіться
спочатку почнемо з правил
представити що ось оце все код та Лінія
тут стінка ззаду
стінка зі стекла вона
не розбивається коли м'яч в неї попадає
тут ще Стекло і тут сітка Тобто ми
граємо в закритій території за закритому
Корці
правило
саме стандартно що вам треба перебивати
через сітку Тобто це як в тенісі вам
треба прибивати через сітку та цей
елемент зі стиком
добавляю ще драйвовість тобто
так давай зараз я ти той перейду і вам
покажу як це працює
також
це бокова стінка тут теж саме якщо м'яч
її торкається це зразу
програмі очко тобто
наша наше завдання лише грати у Корт
також якщо м'яч попадає у сітку м'яч
бронграний і два м'яч можна відбивати
лише з одним відскоком або зльотом якщо
м'яч відскокує два рази це розіграш за
Грани
рахунок як у тенісі хто знайомий з
тенісним рахунком тобто гейми сети і
матч
15:30 40 якщо знайомі і
великий теніс як викликало тенісу це
Тобто це
теніс як лише з елементами
кажуть так
давайте покажу вже удари
стандартного положення от наш код на
корті Ми стоїмо стоїмо завжди лицем якщо
м'яч розпочнемо з удару справу якщо м'яч
летить на право ми стаємо у закриту
стойку
тобто ліва нога спереду
і метою ми так
тобто з ударом Ми повинні
розвернутися у закриту стойку і зробити
замах
трошки нижче
тобто дуже короткий замах та лише рукою
локоть все статично граємо лише ось
такий
ми не нерухомі так і просто проводимо
вперед по м'ячу
це весь удар справа
плюс падав в тому що
в тенісі щоб навчитися грати справу
Тобто потрібно дуже багато часу
на технічну треба відчути м'яч
відчути
свою движение
оце все і це Ви вже вмієте гратись права
вам і стається лише відточнювати це
давайте одразу покажемо удар зліва
зліва все дзеркальне право на нога
впереді то такого ж коротке замах Зліва
і проводимо вперед
граємо лише одною рукою зліва тому що
ручка дуже маленька і для двох років
немає місця
давайте покажемо як ми граємо і потім ви
спробуєте так
Ну що ж друзі бачимо вже почався
майстер-клас від тренера Марка І
сьогодні ми дізнаємося більше про
ракеткові види спорту ми вже дізналися
про падл теніс І я також хочу розповісти
про сквош Тим більше що я бачу що тут у
нас е-е є особливі гості теж нас що
сьогоднішнього дня в нас тут присутні
навіть президент
столичної Федерації скворшу Візьміть
поки м'ячик а Ярослав ганисян п Ярослава
ви тут підходьте до нас Ну розкош ми
знаємо переважно українці як з
голлівудських фільмів завжди заможні
особливо американці бізнесмени хтось в
обідню перерву для підтримання своєї
форми і де грає в сквош Так але здається
що сквош з'являється сьогодні активною в
Україні всі дивилися До речі питання як
це ж з реальних подій 1912 року але мало
хто знає що там теж був майданчик для
сквош хоча б здавалося 110 років тому
які часи А вже британція американці
грали в сквош це справді настільки
крутий але при цьому доступний все ж вид
спорту
з точки зору того чому в голлівудських
фільмах з'являвся сквош а саме серед
еліти або бізнесменів тому що з кожним
Насправді це дуже крутий тренажер для
того щоб якісно і швидко приймати
рішення Тому що під час того коли людина
знаходиться на корті в неї є два дві
зони уваги це суперник якого постійно
потрібно моніторити де він знаходиться і
маленький м'яч для схожий який розміром
в 4 см але він рухається зі швидкістю 28
справжній президент Федерації завжди з
собою м'яч як для сквош
ресурси людини тому з урахуванням того
факту що за годину скворчого людина може
зробити 2000 випав з урахуванням того що
за цю годину людина може втратити від
шести до півтори тисячі калорій це плюс
ще розвантаження для мозку тому що
людина коли заходить на склад на ці 64
м² щастя Вона звідти виходить стомлена
але перезавантажена тому що чисто
фізично ментальних сил не вистачає
думати про проблеми які так чи інакше
але все одно супроводжують життя кожного
українця в тому числі зараз Тобто ми
говоримо про скош як Ну як всі в
принципі ракеткою види спорту там теніс
бадмінтон той же падав навіть настільний
теніс - це великий інтенсив і вскочі теж
це є але іще і дуже особливе правильне
навантаження на мозок а з іншого боку це
розвантаження свідомості коли те що
особливо в людей який багато працюють і
є розумова діяльність ну що вже говорити
про стре говорив в рамках нашого
сьогодення І я так розумію ви не просто
сьогодні не спустими руками У вас є
ракетки є м'яч але ще й тренер і наші
освітяни теж обов'язково сьогодні
спробують познайомити нас з тренером
Ага тут цілий лицар подивіться
куди дитину вклали йому в ракет в руку
ракетку і тепер ця дитина член
національної збірної зі сквожу тому
рівень кваліфікації підтверджується
безпосередньо досягненнями тренера і
саме сьогодні ми будемо давати ті про ті
ті практичні знання які буквально завтра
кожен з вас зможе використати у своєму
спортивному залі Чому Тому що є таке
враження що для того щоб займатись
схожем обов'язково потрібен сквошпорт
але це не так і зараз артемів
продемонструє чому Обов'язково Ще
сьогодні це побачимо артемів як давно
займаєтесь сквощем ну бачимо точно
тримати ракетки ви можете як справжній
досвідчений про коли їх
скільки там штук 60 не менше Наскільки
давно
я займаюся вже близько 9
років тому що як вже казав Ярослав
навантаження на таке велике як у
тенність і тому для мене з кошти дійшов
просто ідеально Ну що ж цікаво буде
познайомитись з квошом Можливо навіть
мене навчать слухайте друзі А давайте
зараз на моєму прикладі тому що в нас
більшість освітян задіяні з Марком
нападл теніс Хоча вони ще доєднаються до
вас так ми кілька візьмемо зараз хтось
можливо нудьгує
і можемо спробувати Ну що ж поки ми
думаємо про те що робити з ракеткою для
сквоша в нас у марка здається все добре
Ідемо до Гуру Падал тенісу Ну що є
перспективи в наших майбутніх чемпіонів
звісно є у кожного своя перспектива
Тобто можна сказати що Падал теніс не
обов'язково для дітей там щоб йшли
ставали профіль можна для кожного в
будь-якому віці Так звісно
впаду приходить і в 50 років в Іспанії
Це дуже популярне діло
лише 10 тренувань та бажань І ви вже
можете грати турніри з категорією б
зробитителями і починати свій Путін Як
давно ви упадалис
два роки вже О бачите як дівчата
вправноті ледь не вбили оператора чи на
з Марком Але все нормально все обійшлося
Тому треба завжди з собою носити ракетку
навіть для скошу якщо що тобто всім
треба спробувати падло так
лише лише бажання і все все получиться
ну що ж все обов'язково вийде і вже
виходить в наших освітян наших вчителів
і я думаю що сьогодні вони не тільки
себе зможуть проявити у Падал тенісі а
тим більше ми бачимо що в нас не так
багато ракеток друзі А в нас є багато
ракеток для сквошу тому ми другу групу
яка зараз нудьгує будемо привчати до ще
одного виду спорту в нас професійний
тренер Артемій Росії також навіть
президент Федерації столичного сквоша
Ярослав
бачите навіть мені вистачило ракета
добре дивіться я зараз вам буду
показувати вправи які направлені саме
для школярів це саме для навчання у
школі на уроках фізичної культури які
можна було використовувати у на уроці
фізичної культури дивіться зараз у
кожного є ракетка я дам м'ячі
це дитячі м'ячі
деяким я дам м'ячі для сквошу ви
подивитися
[сміх]
деяких з вас вже спробували сквош чи
дитячі дати сквош на нашому
презентаційному майданчику деякі
побігали
тепер Дивіться що вам почнемо якщо вже
дитина
ви провели розминку провели початкову
стадію уроку то зараз ми почнемо трохи
знайомити дітей із саме з м'ячем і саме
з ракеткою ми можемо покласти м'яч
на ракетку і щоб діти спробували відчути
як м'яч гойдається на ракеті спробувати
по колу спочатку потім з однієї сторони
з іншої але щоб м'яч не впав з ракетки
так добре наступна буде знову ж таки ми
спробуємо дивіться я зараз з мікрофоном
я буду ви спробувати підкинути м'ячик
щоб він відбився і зловити його на
ракетку ви можете це зробити або руками
за допомогою руки лівої руки або якщо
виходить то без допомоги А добре
дякую
дуже добре Тепер наступний крок ми
спробуємо подьгувати саме м'ячем
понабивати з однієї сторони так
так добре потім спробуємо повернути на
іншу сторону Отже малювати з іншої
сторони деякі вже бачу що прогресують
починають
з різних сторін це робити а тепер
спробуємо трохи повідбивати від підлоги
дивіться з великим дитячим м'ячем це
Вийде дуже легко але саме з м'ячем для
спорту тому що він
дуже низько відскакує треба прикладати
деякі зусилля тому спробуйте трошки
докласти більше зусиль так обережніше
Та добре
наступним кроком буде вже змішування
вправ ми спробуємо на відбити підбити
ударити
надзвичайний просто сквош неможливо не
захопитися цим спортом одразу ж і мені
вже сподобалося я обов'язково спробую
Можливо сьогодні не буде часу нам весь
урок провести разом з тренером артемієм
але і сквош і Падал Теніс - це дуже дуже
цікаво і дуже-дуже вражаюча тому будьте
з нами Ми ще подивимося за падл тенісом
за сквошав Ну і тож скоро будемо
рухатися далі нам ще є про що вам
сказати друзі
ми можемо поділитися зараз на дві
команди кожен зараз візьме м'яч у руки
Та давайте три чоловіки піде на цю
сторону
А що ми зараз спробуємо зробити
дивіться у нас
Ігор Ігор
згадував про те що сквош зустрічається
ця гра згадується в Титаніку та фільму
який я впевнена що всі дивилися але ось
що для мене стало цікавим те що якщо
дивитися Да скрізь історичну призму то
перші згадки цієї гри сягають ще Уявіть
собі 16 століття Чесно кажучи я ось так
не компетентно думала що це дійсно нова
гра вона
молода і давня Як виявилося дисципліна в
спорті в світі тому Ось така цікава
цікава інформація щодо сквоша У той же
час після певного спаду коли він був
популяр 16 столітті на сьогодні він
зараз вже дуже класно І популяризується
я дійсно зустрічаюся зараз тим що багато
моїх знайомих займаються сквошем і знову
ж таки першими є питання коли я про це
дізналася років там 4-5 тому що це
то зараз вже це гра не є новиною ні для
кожного вона популярна
грають і наскільки наскільки стає
зрозумілим наскільки є відомим що ця гра
Вона дійсно виснажує тобто щоб грати
постійно професійно та навіть і не
професійно дуже багато тут окрім
класного фізичного такого класної
фізичної спорт фізичного форуми що
потрібно мати Ну дійсно це ми знову ж
говоримо про зосередженість да про увагу
про кмітливість пропильність про повну
реєстрацію на тому що ти робиш Як ти
граєш
тому тому сквош ось такий він
осучаснений можна говорити про нього ми
можемо обрати будь-я
ку де ви бачите ви спочатку спробуйте
підкинути ліву
руку і відчути саме Від стіни військово-
підлоги
і з лодки щоб відчути як від
намагайтеся не бити сильно головне
завдання щоб Ви навчилися контролювати
саме м'яч щоб він не відлітав по всьому
залу можете підійти трохи ближче
Да і спробувати саме легенько направляти
м'яч
можна направляти з однієї сторони з
іншої
наступним кроком буде вже безпосередньо
гра на пари ви зможете поділитися на
пари
залишити один м'яч на двох
і спробувати на по черзі відбивати але
дивіться знову ж таки головне завдання
навчитися контролювати м'яч і давати
грати вашому напарнику З яким ви стоїте
в парі легенько не сильно
спробуйте яким буде виходити да дитячу
через стіну да ближче підходьте але
через стіну дивіться через стіну
не друг напроти друга а через стіну
то добре
давай
виходить набагато краще
а саме Так ми вже майже навчилися грати
у сквош
і
щоб ще ускладнити гру на
стіні і на підлозі можна намалювати
якісь цілі саме які цілі потрібно
потрапляти м'ячем або на стіні
намагатися помітити або знову ж таки
обережно
так або на полу щоб м'яч завжди
потрапляв у ціль на полу
дивіться дуже цікаво що схож грається
саме у замкненому просторі у вас площа
завжди буде грати чотири стіни але
головною метою потрапити у центральну
стіну і найголовніше фішечкою є у Польщі
те що можна відбувати саме Від бокових
стін від заднього скла що ви можете бити
різноманітні рикошети які можуть гратися
у дві стіни у 200 стіни
і швидкість м'яча під час гри досягає
майже 300 кілометрів на годину рекорд
здається 282 години тому важко потребує
дуже великої концентрації на м'ячі і
реакції
особливо ще те що після удару від стінку
м'яч глушиться на 80% від своєї
початкової швидкості
і це дуже змінює темп гри
Ну що ж друзі Можна говорити про те що
ми булимося вже до фінальної частини
нашої дводенної серпневої конференції
такої спекотної як вона виявилася і в
прямому сенсі тому що дійсно на вулиці
сонечко А хоча був обіцяний дощ і
спекотно в тому плані що дійсно минули
ми минають ці два дні дуже яскраво та
насичено ми бачимо наскільки наскільки
активність велика у тренерів У вчителів
фізичного виховання що я не бачила
жодного Хто б десь стояв та відпочивав
наскільки це дійсно класно круто хочу
трошечки нагадати що ж сьогодні було що
ми з вами бачили чому ми вчилися
на початку була трансляція МОН Про це я
думаю що не ну не не буду перераховувати
все тому що була настільки інформативна
корисна для всіх нас ця конференція тож
всі були залучені всі слухали навчалися
і брали для себе нову інформацію Ну А
далі хочу нагадати
продосконалення освітньої галузі
фізичної культури від Андрія боляка і
Ірини скорбун і методичні особливості
проведення уроку фізичної культури в
класі з інклюзивним навчанням про це
говорила дуже влучна Олена Аксьонова
пам'ятаєте VR де ми з вами були свідками
того як пробували себе учні та й дорослі
У віртуальній реальності одягаючи
окуляри і ми дійсно спочатку думали про
те що це лише віртуальність це лише
комп'ютерні ігри але насправді як е-е
підтвердженням всього Бог став е-е Ігор
в тому що дійсно потрібно для цього не
лише
спостерігати А і ще гарний вестибулярний
апарат А що це значить що потрібно
тренуватися координація і фізична
підготовка тому що навіть влежати
Вибачте На цьому VR тренажері треба
вміти і мати силу цікаво і пізнавально
було це е пам'ятаєте далі ми з вами
завітали подивилися на кіберфутбол і
переконалася в тому що є альтернатива
звичайним
стрілялкам я назву так як ми називаємо
це е в житті і ця альтернатива Вона
дійсно дуже крута тому що діти грають у
футбол діти граються певну команду діти
знають і вивчають якщо не знають гравців
кожної команди Звісно що кожен є Фаворит
у кожного гравця у кожного дитину кожної
дитини кожної людини кожного
вболівальника є свій по Фаворит свій
гравець своя команда і тут є змога ще й
пограти дуже класно і якісно дійсно Дуже
якісно промальована гра тому
грати в не одне задоволення можна можна
говорити про багато чого згадаю да курей
скул Games щойно Ми дивилися сквош
волейбол і Падал теніс активно дієво
круто прийшли минули ці два дні я
впевнена в тому що отримали ми
задоволення точно від того що тут
відбувалося вдячні що ви були Ну що ж я
вже бачу і ви разом зі мною бачите що
Ігор вже стартовій залі а це значить що
тут тепер наша головна і основна локація
тут буде відбуватися далі наступне
цікаве і дуже важливе для кожного
учасника цієї конференції дійсно Ігор як
там настрій
практикум щодо розвитку фізичної
культури та спортивної підготовки серед
учнівської молоді його довга назва має
ще більш важливе значення Тим більше що
відбувається він в рамках всеукраїнської
серпневої конференції 2022 І знаєте
насправді він підходить до свого
завершення але є ще головний момент ось
для мене особисто я думаю як і для
багатьох українців Хто захоплюється
спортом в спорті Важливо не тільки саме
змагання але й момент нагородження
згадайте Лише так фінал Ліги чемпіонів з
футболу чи олімпійські і ігри це завжди
круто Так коли підіймають кубок чи
отримують атлети медалі особливо коли
синьо-жовтий прапор України так стоїть
чемпіон і каже всім що звичайно ж Слава
Україні
ну непогано хтось займався спортом але
якщо Ось так сказати щоб вас почули не
тільки в домінанті але й на правому
березі Дніпра в українському Криму в
українському Донецьку в Херсоні в
Чернігові Закарпатті Слава Україні
і Умань Ну звичайно Умань теж наша Умань
нас чує Умань привіт і Маріуполь теж
бачите в нас звідусіть зі всієї України
всі нас чують всі на нас бачать і мені
подобається що ви такі дійсно
патріотичні ви такі активні ви такі
здорові і ви такі головне круті і для
того щоб вручати ось ці трофеї Хто хоче
подарунок всі хочуть подарунок Я думаю
глядачі а тут вже руки підняли і готові
готові брати Ну будемо зараз знаєте
дізнаватися Чи ви дійсно сьогодні
займалися спортом Чи ви брали участь в
усіх наших локаціях активностей Чи ви
дійсно заслужили на цей Трофей і для
того щоб чемпіон отримав свій Трофей
звичайно треба відповідно особливі дуже
особистості Отож я радий сюди запросити
Володимира артамоного ваші Оплески
заступник голови пам'ятаєте у фізичної
культури та спорту Міністерства освіти і
науки України Отож фізичне виховання в
нас на високому рівні Я думаю що не
можна не тішитись цього приводу
Дякую Так правильно зазначив Ігор і
фізичне виховання рухова активність та
здоровий спосіб життя це пріоритети
освіти і Школярі які закінчують
шкільні заклади вони повинні бути
вмотивовані на протязі всього життя
займатися
руховою активністю вести здоровий спосіб
життя Отже діти на сьогодні ваша ваша
функція вашої активності завершилась
Скажіть вам сподобалось
О це це дуже добре
це чутно що сподобалось
ви сьогодні
грали в cool games Cool рейс поєднання
кіберспорту та рухової активності також
були квести і були і що ще було у вас
і флешмобу так молодці Зараз ми
хочемо відзначити вашу участь подякувати
вашим батькам вашим вчителям і ваші
активності тож ми кожного кожного
учня нагороджуємо ось такою бутылочкою
це цілий Трофей А давайте так хай
підніметься ті по-перше Оплески собі ви
сьогодні класно змагались а тепер будемо
дійсно дізнаватися чи брали ви участь
яка класно ще й синього патріотичного о
підтримка ще й захисників України краще
всього дійсно підтримати їх спортом і
свою активністю хто сьогодні займався
Cool Game з підніміться будь ласка
піднімайтесь не бійтесь cool games
підходьте сюди отримувати теж свої
трофеї cool games - це винахід України
винахід нашого комітету вічного
виховання для спорту
Міністерства освіти і науки України
грають в Україні грають по всьому світу
і школярі і дорослі
А хто сьогодні бігав
курейс будь ласка піднімайтеся тільки ті
виходять хто ще не отримував Трофей
звичайно щоб вистачило для всіх нас
трофеїв
окрім того в нас сьогодні був
кіберспорт
ігор футбол з руковою активністю ми
грали і в звичайний Футбол і Футбол тут
Фіфу в чудових умовах ви теж
заслуговуєте як справжній чемпіони не
тільки спортивні і кіберспортивні але і
чемпіони життя вітаємо Ну і не забуваємо
що в нас сьогодні був ще й квест і
спортивне орієнтування хто займався
кому сподобався сьогоднішній квест
бачимо вже пляшечки так дивляться Ну і
також всі займалися сьогодні VR і всі
також в нас політали там по змагалися на
лижах а всі отримали До речі діти всі
Отримали свою трофейну пляшку переможну
молодці ну це чудово Так в нас діти
Сьогодні вже отримали свої нагороди Ну і
скоро ми будемо нагороджувати і наших
вчителів Як я розумію в них зараз
завершується модульний урок фізкультури
там в залі в нас ракеткові види спорту
падл теніс і сквош і вони прийдуть сюди
Отож чекаємо на них
[музика]
Ну що ж ми чекаємо чекаємо колег чекаємо
освітян після уроків після мабуть
все-таки не можуть вони Відірватися від
ігор в яких зараз беруть участь Так це
схоже Теніс - це останнє наша локація
пам'ятаєте Ми спостерігали і вже скоро
повертаються вчителів для отримання
своїх сертифікатів які дійсно дуже
важливі для
зросту себе як
професіонала своєї справи Так тому зараз
всі ці всі-всі-всі освітяни що були
присутні на
серпневі конференції вони два дні це
було задоволення поєднав поєднуючи з
навчанням тому дійсно це заслужена така
нагорода сертифікат що сьогодні був буде
вручений всім учасникам цієї
конференції Ну а ми поки що будемо
чекати на вчителів тут і це вже дійсно
вже завершальний етап і для кого ми
будемо говорити до зустрічі Ну а поки що
ми з вами трошечки Ще почекаємо
почекаємо до того що вже всі ми
одночасно вручити ці сертифікати
безперечно заслуженість чи сертифікати
безперечно важливий сертифікати хочу
сказати ще раз що дуже важливо тут
Можливо хтось хотів доєднатися офлайн і
неможливо Точно я знаю що Так є
доєднатися і бути тут і відчути цю
атмосферу такої дружби єдності
освітянської
з якихось причин не вийшло відвідати
приїхати ну знаєте що вона буде І
наступного року і причини для зустрічі Я
сподіваюся що вже скоро будуть для всіх
нас вже там реальними для офлайн
зустрічі Я маю на увазі коли ми будемо
поновлювати такі дуже хочеться Вже
повернутися в таке активне спортивне
життя і
дійсно запросити сюди до нас в Україну
інші країни Відвідати не
тільки як допомога Україні а вже як
брати участь у
питому українських питома українських
е-е
змаганнях такі як Cool Race і
cool games дійсно ми Нам є чим пишатися
погодьтеся що ми можемо говорити з
гордістю і
відчуттям своєї такої
незабутності та унікальності що два дуже
важливі дуже класні проекти такі як cool
games і cool games започатковані тут в
Україні і їх знають лише завдяки нам
тому що Ви думали придумали реалізували
і дали життя
мотивувались заохотили Ми українці Ми
творимо історію разом з вами друзі і
сподіваємось на те щоб дуже-дуже-дуже
скоро ми з вами зустрінемося всі офлайн
Ну а вже скоро ми тим учасником які
змогли такі відвідати
серпневу конференцію ми
будемо вручати сертифікати будемо Будемо
розуміти коли це почнеться вже дуже-дуже
входом Ну а поки що
поки що буду ще раз говорити вам дякую
що ви такі є що ви мотивуєте що ви
активно залучаєте своїх учнів та учениць
до занять спорту оскільки дійсно
спортивне спортивні секції спортивні
ігри уроки фізичної культури вони
розвивають не лише фізичні можливості
дитини а і
інші компетентності такі як творчість
таке кмітливість і тощо Тому це дійсно
дуже-дуже важливо залучати якомога
більше дітей Ну а здоровий здорове тіло
здорової нації Ти здорова нація
відповідно
ну що вже зібралися зібралися прийшли
прийшли все освітяни вчителі повернулися
з майстер-класів і я задоволенням
передаю слово туди до актової зали Ігоря
Ну як настрій Я вже запитувала Як
настрій освітян передавай від мене
привіт Ви мене вони мене не чують перед
тебе під мене привіт І я вже буду
спостерігати за тим що буде відбуватися
Дякую Катя дійсно освітяни надзвичайні
значно скільки вони були бадьорі і Вчора
вранці і сьогодні протягом всього дня
Зараз вони вже такі знаєш філософські Як
говорив наш класик Думи мої думи десь
пори все ви всередину але думаю зараз
все буде дуже і дуже бурхливо а тим
більше що зараз момент знаєте підводити
підсумок і завершувати ці надзвичайні
дні Цей марафон який буде безумовно
фундаментом для нового навчального року
а з ними великого і позитивного майбуття
для нашої великої України буде перемога
і буде все добре а тому знаєте ось такий
солодкий навіть дещо пафосний важливий
момент треба підкреслити особливими ще
спікерами тому також під ваші Оплески
друзі зустрічайте о Володимира артемова
давай заступник голови комітету
фізичного виховання та спорту
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Володимира будь ласка дякую
Дякую що завершилась
міжнародна Серпнева конференція і наша
локація яка назвалась активна школа
здорова Україна в рамках цієї
конференції ці два дні вони були дуже
насичені вони дуже потужні дуже
змістовні вчителі показали ті
напрацювання які готували протягом року
діти по позмагалися
прийняли участь у активностях
Все було дуже круто Це дуже було
мені дуже сподобалось Я впевнений що
сподобалось кожному із тих хто був тут і
кожному з тих хто дивився і стежив за
нами онлайн
я хочу подякувати вам за те що ви змогли
знайти можливість приїхати поділитись
своїми знаннями
всім глядачам які були з нами онлайн
[музика]
школі і Домінанта в якій все Це
відбувалось ну і звісно всіма
організаторам всім тим хто долучився до
організації сім партнером зараз буде
відбуватися
фінальна лінія видача сертифікатів
вчителям і
ми її Сподіваємось що в наступному році
бо це традиційна конференція
Серпнева перед початком року в
наступному році ми ще раз з вами
зустрінемось
А за цей рік
всі маємо
надію на те що військовий стан
завершиться і все буде добре у нас дякую
Дякуємо Володимир хочу також сюди
запросити Андрія воляка теж нас
заступник голови комітету фізичного
виховання та спорту Міністерства освіти
і науки України кандидат наук з
фізичного виховання і спорту України не
всі реалії встигну сказати і Володимира
і Андрія але все ж у нас чемпіони з усіх
боків Куди не Поглянь і настрій має бути
чемпіонський попри ті важкі часи в яких
ми живемо Дякую Друзі Ну я думаю що ми
разом з вами зараз оплесками подякуємо
тій команді яка створила це маленьке
додене чудо яке ми як учасниками якого
ми були будь ласка
що це дійсно вагомий вагомий захід який
прокладає тренди на наступний навчальний
рік і користуючись нагодою користуючись
того того що йде зараз
трансляція ми все ж таки маємо дати
фідбек коротенький про те що власне
сьогодні 4 побачили І про що запитували
бо ключовим моментом для для всіх
вчителів які починають працювати за
навчальними навчальною програмою є
наступні питання які ми виокремили і з
чатів і зараз я їх за 30 секунд
прокоментую перше що на модельному уроці
ви бачили одночасно паралельне
проведення трьох варіативних модулів і
цей Ви бачили що це абсолютно реально
друга позиція коли ми говоримо про те що
неможливо Чи малий зал проводити ці
модулі паралельно то ми можемо говорити
про використання роботи по колу в той же
час слід розуміти що коли ми говоримо
про повноцінний вибір дитини то можливо
той варіативний модуль він хотів його
уникнути тому він обрав інший І працюючи
по колу Ми створюємо ситуацію
дискомфорту для дитини Тож давайте
думати в першу чергу про дитину про її
особистий вибір
наступна позиція якщо мала площа в залі
на стадіоні питань взагалі немає з
трьома модулями якщо мала площа то
Зверніть увагу на ті модулі бо там дуже
багато таких видів які можна проводити
на обмеженій площі і це абсолютно
реально в кого це не виходить
телефонуйте нам ми вам підкажемо які
модулі дуже зручно поєднати і останнє що
хотілось би що хотілось би зазначити
власне думайте про дітей
в першу чергу думайте про їх інтерес і я
думаю що діти будуть вам вдячні за це
оце коротеньке що хотілось би про
самопідкреслити В нашій роботі і хочу
звернути увагу що модельна Програма вона
містить саме закладені вніс Саме ці
меседжі тож їх треба дотримуватися крім
цього модельна програма містить
рекомендації по організації
фізкультурно-оздоровчої діяльності на
яку я хотів би щоб ви звернули увагу бо
модулі на уроках Вони мають бути
продовжені у фізкультурно-оздоровчих
діяльності і це запорука того що діти
наші знайдуть
врешті-решт свій вид спорту любов до
якого вони принесуть через це життя
колеги Дякую що дочекалися Ну що зараз
тоді
найхвилюші момент як сказав Володимир
найважливіший це вручення сертифікатів
спочатку вона допоможете Я пропоную
Таким чином я буду зачитувати один
робити вручати
підходьте Ну що ж справжня команда також
прошу
Ну я ж запрошую
аж бачимо справжня команда Коли завжди
можна підтримати один одного і ще і
пожартувати нам до Володимира ближче я
буду
я буду зачитувати
бедров Артур
Петро так можна підтримати одне одного
без рук катеринами
Білаш Євгенія
Божок Олександр
Величко Орест
галій Максим
[музика]
Гесик Мирослав
Ми йдемо такими чемпіонськими темпами
Глоба Марія
Глушко Роман
зіньковський Даніїл
комин до Максим
Коротич Анастасія
король Ірина
не всі поки дійшли Кузьменко Вікторія
Лещук Світлана
Мошків Олена
малише Володимир
Новицька любов
угонисян Ярослав
біжить Ярослав прямісінько зі сквошу
[музика]
пархомович Володимир
Пасічник Ірина
Перун Артем
момент тріумфо
вже Потайчук борис вже усіх дипломи
ніхто не може Оплески Іван
Савік Дмитро
Сичик Галина
Павло
[музика]
скутер Марина
Соболенко Владислав
[музика]
шкарпета Віталій
Шумейко Дарина
шоста Юлія давайте друзі всі мають
отримати сертифікат
Цуркан Сергій
Яковлев Анатолій
І це ще не все
[музика]
Бачите як відчувається
зворотнього боку Здається цей сертифікат
Ось бачите Який в нас вчителі які
освітяни як Вони все бачать з усіх
Шановні колеги за підсумками нашої
роботи має бути затверджена резолюція
тож я пропоную нашим нашими такими
зібранням доручити доручити
Володимиру артамонову Галині коломоєць
Андрій боляков напрацювати проект
резолюції потім ми
розішлимо для того щоб ви могли
ознайомитися ми зберемо пропозиції і вже
і подамо до Міністерства освіти науки
Можливо ми домовлялися на початку що в
кого є пропозиції ви їх можете донести
зразу відразу після нашого нашого
зібрання теперішнього або надіслати
поштою телефоном будь-яким іншим
способом тож чекаємо на ваші пропозиції
до загальної спільної резолюції
Ну і що ж для завершального акорду не
тільки ваші Оплески бурхливі але й
спільне фото хтось сюди дійшов Давайте
швидше зробимо цей красивий фінальний
кадр ану всі хто не тримає камери в
руках підходьте сюди друзі тому що
дійсно наш всеукраїнський семінар
практикум щодо розвитку фізичної
культури та спортивної підготовки серед
учнівської молоді в рамках
всеукраїнської серпневої конференції
абсолютно
вдався друзі і ми знаємо що все буде
добре Україна
переможе все буде Україна і давайте за
традицією як завжди рахуємо до трьох І
кажемо головне слово для всіх нас 1 2 3
Україна
[музика]
і ще раз тільки з руками один два три
Україна
[музика]
дійсно друзі знаєте як би не було
складно якби не було трагічно тяжко і
сльозливо в ці дні тому що це великий
біль великий сум але за великою війною
пройде велика перемога ми вдячні Богові
вдячні нашій країні всьому нашому
народові Я ще є нашій владі друзі тому
що уряд президент роблять все задля
Перемоги і звичайно наша армія звичайно
Сьогодні ми бачили як працює ДСНС
рятувальники звичайно лікарі І звісно ж
вчителі друзі освітяни всі ми йдемо
єдиним фронтом і наближеним момент
великої Перемоги великої України Отож
друзі Слава Україні
і Україна перемагай
[музика]